Bam,
all right.
We're live,
ladies and gentlemen with a whole new
setup.
A.
Yeah.
When they listen man,
I'm very irresponsible.
You know,
it's gonna be really cool is when we get
something right back here.
That's the next step.
We're trying to figure out what to put
right back there.
Most likely is going to be a green
screen because I'm looking at this right
now.
I'm like,
how dope would it be if we were in
fucking space right now?
We can have like captain Kurt ship
behind us like late also.
We have a real desk.
Um,
we have real microphones now,
so,
uh,
the iphone version and IPAD and I,
whatever the fuck you use,
MP3 is going to be much better,
much clearer.
And we're fucking fired up.
We are not sponsored by starbucks.
This is just coincidence that we have to
happen to have that.
But we have had an offer for our very
first sponsor and it is the fleshlight
awesome.
I got some funny to tell you,
Joe,
by the way.
Hold on a second.
We've got to tell people.
So the fleshlight
is,
uh,
if you don't know what it is,
if you're,
you're,
you're not a,
an online type person,
it's a,
a very famous device that you can fuck.
And uh,
one of the reasons why it's famous
because it's supposed to feel really
good.
It's supposed to feel like way better
than your hand.
And the other reason is that there was
that,
that thing that was online,
like I accidentally the whole
flashlight.
What was that Guy Pranking?
Uh,
I think it was a customer service rep
that a saying only as something that he,
he is a flashlight or something like it
was a really bad accident.
No flush Elo Carola.
Well cat,
well this guy
watched that or heard that thing or
remember it.
But I do remember that that fleshlight
thing got stuck in my head because of
that because everybody kept saying it.
And uh,
it just,
it's,
it's like one of those things where
like,
you,
you know,
you hear about it so often on the
internet just because of that.
So when they contacted me I was like,
wow,
that's kinda cool.
Then when he told me that he sponsored a
Kevin Smith podcasts,
I'm like,
wow,
that's super cool.
Like he's going to do our podcast and
Kevin Smith's podcast.
That sounds fucking bad ass.
And then we met the dude and Chris was a
super cool guy and uh,
you know,
uh,
just a real chill do that you could hang
with like a normal guy.
And he was really a kind of a spiritual
guy too,
which is kind of interesting because we
were talking about the porn side and
how,
you know,
porn is kind of gross,
there's a lot of porn now that you don't
really would necessarily want to be
associated with either really good at
his job researching you because he
seemed like your long lost brother
document because he was like pulling out
documentaries you didn't even know
about,
like books that I didn't know about when
that was the weird,
like you guys would be good for.
You guys were gay.
You'd be perfect.
Perfect Lover,
lover.
Yeah.
He was
real bright guy,
man.
When we talked about me and Musashi,
we talked about different schools of
philosophy,
different books that he's read.
Yes.
Different.
Uh,
different volcanoes.
He knew about some super volcanoes
exploding in the past that I didn't
even.
Right.
You got to get them on the shelf.
Yes,
definitely.
He,
unfortunately,
he lives in Austin,
but the next time we're in Austin,
what we'll do is we'll bring our
equipment and everything is set up in
Austin or we can move there.
I fucked up.
I fucked up moving to Colorado for a
bunch of reasons.
One,
because Mrs Rogan can't fucking drive in
the snow,
which is just a,
it's not good.
And if you know Mrs Rogan,
that's not something that I'm going to
be comfortable with her learning really
quickly.
Just that doesn't seem like a good move.
Just fucking moving where it's freezes
and shit gets dangerous and sliding the
trees and shit.
And then when the dog,
when the dog got eaten by the mountain
lion,
that killed it.
Yeah.
Otherwise,
Austin would have been great.
And if our.
Anyway,
the point is if Austin was great,
we would definitely hang around with
Chris Kelly,
but what's funny is he gave us a sample
so we can feel and touch it of the
flashlight and the fleshlight uses
patent and rubber technology.
They have a patent on this shit.
Yeah.
It's a very specific type of insert.
The bushy squishy stuff has their own
proprietary blends.
Yeah,
and it's like you,
you think in your head like,
Oh,
I'm sure it feels like rubber and oil.
Like it's not gonna.
It's just gonna feel like really soft
rubber.
This actually is kind of creepy to feel
it.
Was He.
He gave us a sample.
What he did is he took a couple of
flashlights and he cut it in half just
so we can feel the actual rubber part
and then at the end of our dentists and
really feel like puts you though.
It felt.
It feels soft.
Yeah,
it feels really good.
It feels really.
Hasn't even moved up though.
No,
it's not even lose.
So he gave us the samples too.
Mushy.
It's like a pushy that sick.
Well because it's usually in a can.
It's usually,
it's,
it's got some bonus
behind you want like,
oh,
but wouldn't,
would that make it more clear?
Yeah.
Because you have like a wall right now.
We actually have a box of them.
Yeah.
So anyways,
he gave us these samples,
just a few of them and we left them on
the table and I'm like,
you're not going to take that.
And he was like,
Oh,
you know,
it's just trash just so you can see
like,
you know what I'm going to take it.
So I took the samples and I had it there
in a bag and the other day,
uh,
I decided when no one was around that I
would try to fuck one of the samples,
but it was only half of it.
So have you used both of them?
One for the bottom and one for the top.
And so it's doing the left hand and the
right hand left hand was the left
sample,
the right with the right sample.
And I'm like,
wait a second,
fleshlight company you need something
like that.
Because I had like two different hand
jobs going on.
I had one with a different texture on
the top.
One on yourself off with two hands like
you're milking.
Milking a cow will.
How you work in the balls.
It's hung on the bottom.
I put the balls in the bottom one.
I wrapped it around the bottom one.
So it's kind of to your balls around the
bottom one.
How fucking smaller balls.
They're very,
very small,
but I was doing both of them.
I used to eat a lot of Nmr.
You remember the falls?
She cried,
but anyways,
it felt really real.
I only had hot water and lube.
Yeah,
for a loop,
but it felt really good,
like shampoo or something I'm good at
because it's supposed to be a water
based oil and that.
So they felt good for even just being
samples outside of its cocoon and
everything.
It wasn't even in the can or anything,
so I can't wait to fuck one of these
things.
Is this one of them right now?
These are.
These are the ones.
This is not without some controversy.
I don't.
This is actually going to be really
loud,
so to speak softly as possible.
I'm willing to do it
so it's not annoying.
This is a.
apparently this is a,
this is the fleshlight wow.
It comes in a nice packaging like,
like,
are you going to do an unboxing video
for us,
Joe?
Yes.
We'll do the flashlight.
Let's see what we got here.
Now this is not without some controversy
and this is where it gets strange.
Um,
my manager is very,
very upset with me.
Yeah.
And does not think that the fleshlight
is a good thing to have for a sponsor.
And um,
I was surprised with that because they
were like really adamant about it.
They were like,
you could be up for some sort of a show
cbs and they find out that you have the
flashlight on,
on your podcast.
You know,
that you're sponsored by a thing,
not just that you have an opinion about
a thing.
They were saying that the big deal is
that you are sponsored by this thing and
because you're sponsored by this thing
somehow or another that makes you like,
what does that make you?
A bad person?
Yes.
Because you don't masturbate your hand.
Yeah.
You're,
you're,
you're a bad person because you
preferred to masturbate with the rubber
vagina.
Right.
Like really
old school.
It's crazy talk,
right?
Like,
it's crazy the idea that you don't
masturbate if you don't masturbate.
What's wrong with you?
Like it's a,
it's a great.
Feels good.
Okay.
First of all to.
It's a great way of getting a release,
like a sexual release.
So it's not built up.
It's on annoying you all day because if
you're not getting laid.
Okay.
And a lot of us aren't.
If you're not getting laid and you don't
jerk off,
you're going to go fucking bananas.
Right?
Yeah,
that's,
that's a fact.
It's totally fair.
So what is this some sort of a leftover
purity?
Yeah.
Don't show your ankles,
your ankles.
Technology.
Fucking
put dresses over the legs of chairs.
You ever seen those,
those buildings where they put or those,
uh,
old uh,
um,
like furniture from like,
you know,
I don't know what year it was,
way,
way back in the Victorian era.
I guess when they put,
they would literally put dresses around
the legs of chair,
a place like lacey so that people don't
get excited by fucking chair,
but it was like Brah you remember go to
your grandmother's house and seeing like
that old white croquet kit table was.
What was it called?
It was kind of like a white lacey,
you know,
old people.
Dolese.
Is that what is doily?
I don't think it's the same thing.
I don't think.
Oh,
look at you.
You're doing it.
Any Bravo right now?
You fuck you.
Fuck my sits on airplane mode.
I thought,
oh well I'm going to put them on there.
So yeah.
So they used to put doilies type shit on
furniture that was almost like lace of a
bra to cover up the.
The ankles of a chair or a leg of a
table.
Crazier people.
How fucking
crazier people and how crazy is that?
Me Of all people,
like all the shit that I've talked about
from fucking dmt to the fact that I
think the government,
Kennedy and the same people are probably
in power and giant fucking corporations
control the world.
And
you have a video of you and me watching
two girls and one cup and then you
showing no,
you've got to watch a video of a Guy Cha
chopping off their debt,
but yet you can't masturbate.
That's okay.
But masturbation is terrible.
It's,
it makes no sense at all of all the shit
that I'm put it up on the Internet.
I try to be as honest as possible and I
try to put as much on the Internet about
things that I'm interested in.
I don't care if you think I'm crazy and
out there.
I don't care if you know,
you think it's inappropriate or look,
I'm just curious about this certain
subject.
Here it is.
Whether it's on my message board or
whether we're talking about on this,
this,
a podcast or whether we put it on
twitter,
you know,
if I find something,
I think it's interesting.
I'm going to be honest about it.
Like why is that a fucking bad thing?
You know?
And why is the idea of me fucking this
rubber flashlight?
Why is that a bad thing?
Because I don't think people in Middle
America wants to think of you
masturbating and then if that gets
thrown in their faces.
Yeah,
because you're not supposed to hand in
their face.
You're not supposed to have sex too.
So that's what it is when,
when you don't want people to see people
having sex or talking about sex too much
and if you endorse sex with yourself,
that's a bad thing.
I don't know.
I,
to me it's like,
I mean,
you can't marry that with the craziest.
The thing is they said,
the manager said that,
uh,
that one of the things that we're
talking about was the fact that this
isn't the pornography industry.
That's what they said.
It's the pornography that it's
pornography.
And I said,
how is it involved in pornography
industry?
It's,
it's like it's just a rubber vagina.
They're like,
well,
when you use it you watch pornography.
So that was an actual argument.
So,
so like how can we can't do it?
You can either do it with your
imagination.
It has to involve pornography.
Joe,
how many,
how many documentaries have you done on
DMT and drugs?
So the drug industry's okay,
but the porn industry,
the Janet Jackson Nipple industry is
just out of control.
Insane.
It's why.
I don't know what you just said.
You might pay a little bit too much to
talk right now.
You know what I'm saying?
Many rambled with your women's
documentaries.
Have you done about drugs?
I've done.
So the drug industry to your managers
fine with drug industry is not really an
industry.
Well,
the idea is that a documentary is
different because it's just your opinion
on a certain subject.
Whereas this is an endorsement.
That's the argument.
Endorsement endorsements were endorsed
by marijuana.
Was marijuana is illegal.
You are endorsed by marijuana and
endorsement.
Marijuana.
Actually none of the only sponsors this
show.
It writes most of the material and
causes most of the things to happen.
And he's the producer with marijuana is
the senior producer.
Train wreck.
This week it was green crack,
crack.
Crack is executive producer,
secret executive producer of this show
this week.
Yeah.
No Shit.
So,
so this is a real argument right now.
The real argument is that if I endorse
this thing that somehow or another,
it would be a bad thing.
Packaging on.
That's.
I think that's the butthole is have,
but maybe that's the vagina.
Wow.
This is a super tight.
No.
Can we just touch it and they put.
They
give me one and a half.
I've been wearing them.
I don't want to have her.
Do you have a loop?
A One?
Have a loop.
Hey,
if you guys know Lupus.
She was on the Howard Stern show.
It's like Christmas.
Listen,
this ain't no motherfucking clear.
The table of all the junk.
This is way less annoying than the way I
used to have.
Yeah,
there's some junk on the table.
How about this?
I'll take this out.
Move this out of the way with that
helping.
It does look a little bit if I do that.
How about that?
I'm cleaning up for you guys.
That's the difference between the
ustream crowd and the iphone.
IPAD,
ipod crowd.
So that's the flashlight fellow.
Fuck it.
I got the stamina training unit.
Did you have to practice v longer in
bed?
It says,
every man knows,
the only way to get better is to
practice view can last 10 minutes in the
unit.
You can last 20 minutes in bed with
anyone.
Wow,
that's bold.
That's strong words.
That was one of the things that this guy
was telling us.
What's one of the more fascinating
things about this whole thing was the
actual therapeutic applications of the
flashlight,
and this sounds like nonsense.
Sounds like someone's just justifying
trying to fuck a rubber pussy,
but know what they use them for a bunch
of different therapeutic reasons.
And one of them is a,
people in certain religions aren't
allowed to touch their penis and because
they're not allowed to touch their
penis.
These guys,
he said that his city Jews in particular
actually have a hard time,
um,
orgasming when they have sex with women
because they're so used to like fucking
pillows because they do most of their
masturbation like grabbing a sheet or
grabbing a pillow.
This is his words,
not mine.
This,
this could be totally nonsense.
I don't know.
I have not researched this at all.
That's my caveat.
But he said that,
um,
the flashlight is actually covered by
some insurance policies as therapy,
as sexual therapy,
to get them to learn how to orgasm with
a vagina instead of fucking like some
rough pillow.
So I don't know.
I have not validated this.
I don't know whether that's true.
Yeah,
it totally makes sense to me.
And the other reason for the fresh
flashlight is it trains guys not to
prematurely ejaculate.
And guys who have problems with
premature ejaculation,
they can practice in the flashlight.
That's the idea.
You're supposed to take this to.
Oh,
that doesn't,
doesn't feel good.
Metal plastic card asked him.
Yeah,
don't get too crazy.
Pull your Dick outside.
I'll fucking panic.
So,
um,
so I don't think there's any.
Look,
obviously we all masturbate.
It's,
it's silly at this point in this stage
of life to,
to deny that it,
it's,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's dumb.
So if we all masturbate,
what is the,
what's wrong with this thing?
You know,
what's wrong with this?
You know what's crazy?
I do things like smoke cigarettes are
used to smoke cigarettes in the car and
have a of of my hand.
I think therapeutically I can put this
in my car instead of smoking cigarettes.
Just finger.
It doesn't feel so good.
I mean,
don't touch my butt.
I mean that's something to do with my
hand.
Like,
like,
like that feels good.
That feels like I'm playing with like
one of those stress balls,
but it actually feels like I'm 10
percent woman doing it.
Wow.
Touching on strong numbers.
Let's strong number son.
I think there is a lot of things like
that because there was something else
you were saying about people.
A lot of medical reasons.
Like was something else that he said
besides that,
uh,
religion.
There was like doctors that would use it
for a while.
The,
we already recovered that.
Doctors use it for premature ejaculation
and religions that don't masturbate.
You're way too high on lady here.
He blasted.
Seems distracted.
That's why I tried to keep the ipad away
from him.
I told you I took one too many hits
today.
He did take one to many and went over
the deep end king outside.
It's my fault.
Um,
so what,
what I don't understand.
And I don't wanna I don't wanna I
definitely wanna hear from you guys.
I'm just let me know on twitter at Joe
Rogan.
I'm just my name now.
Joe Rogan.
He used to be doc.net
[inaudible] dot net because some dudes
cybersquatting on my name but I got it
back.
Thank you very much.
Twitter,
my account got verified and all that
shit.
Um,
but I,
I want to know,
do you think it's ridiculous because I
think it's ridiculous.
And what is there?
Is there really a bunch of you out there
that would not want to see something and
I'm doing whatever the fuck it is
because you know that I support rubber
pussies.
Like is it possible that that could cost
somebody's business?
I mean in this day and age when the
fucking pope.
Okay,
it's not being brought to justice for
shielding child molesters.
You're really going to get upset at me
if I endorse her rubber pushing me.
The pope has endorsed by the goddamn
presidents of every goddamn country in
the world and this guy shielded,
shielded pedophiles.
I mean,
it's a fact.
He did.
He's a,
he's a part of the problem with the
Catholic Church.
That motherfucker is accepted
everywhere,
but I'll be about,
am I comparing myself to the pope?
I guess I am.
Folks.
I just fucked up.
I did.
I don't know why there's some grandy
grandiose delusions of grandeur in my
head.
I connect my because I've always wanted
aware of it.
Dope as robe show,
show up for work dressed like a marilyn.
But you know,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with masturbating.
Obviously you don't either.
We all,
we all do it.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with a product that makes masturbation
easier or better.
And that's what it is.
I support it and you know,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm not going to listen to my managers.
I'm gonna tell him
go fuck themselves.
But he made it,
but I love them.
You made an awesome point like women in
their dildos and vibrators that almost,
you know,
when people get married at like bachelor
parties and stuff,
that's like a joke,
you know,
that's like,
that's their toy.
Guys have never really had any,
any,
any real legit toys.
You know,
it's true.
This is the first one that actually
makes sense.
Instead of using your hand.
When did you use something that feels
100 times better?
Yeah,
that is the art and I can't wait to fuck
it and I may get a cantaloupe,
put it in the microwave,
microwave,
put a little hole in it and warm it up a
little and we fucked that first.
Wait a half hour and then fuck this and
see which one's better.
Cantaloupe is your move,
right?
You've done that before.
I've done it before.
It's great because you.
After you fuck it,
you could totally eat it,
so I just wash it out.
Don't even layer,
don't eat,
don't eat the layer rude.
Someone calling during my fucking
podcast.
I would shut that off.
I knew it was cliche management.
They're there.
They're listening to the podcast right
now,
like,
hey man,
let's talk about this man.
Put this out there.
That's funny that your managers.
That's cool.
That doesn't stop because you'd start
talking to that.
No,
just
listen.
That's hilarious.
It's hilarious.
They called right when we're talking
about,
you know,
I see what they're saying.
They're trying to protect me from like,
you know,
like if I had to do a show like fear
factor or something like that,
maybe that could be a problem.
Yeah.
But you'd still.
Producers Horses.
Dick's.
Yeah.
I feel like you got to take me as I am.
You know,
I'm not a bad guy.
Whenever you don't want to do some sort
of.
I don't want to do a fear factor again.
I really don't.
I mean it's so tempting not to for the
money,
but I got to do something more
interesting.
I got to do shit that I like doing
because I have so much more fun.
So it's almost like getting in bed with
a flashlight.
It's like protects me from doing
anything stupid that I know I'll do for
money.
You know?
It's just so easy when something like
fear factor comes along and they're
like,
hey,
we're going to give you all this money
every week and only have to do is just
show up and watch people do stupid shit.
You're like,
fuck,
it's so easy to get that money.
It's so difficult,
but you have got a pass on it.
You really do.
Because if it was good that I did it,
but at a certain point in time you have
to pass on doing those things because if
you don't,
you're just going to be better.
You're talking about,
by the way,
you're talking about old TV while you
while you're doing new TV.
Yeah.
This is way easier.
This look,
we could have never had a fucking show
like this that reaches as many people as
this thing does.
Including the,
um,
you know,
the podcast on itunes and this thing on
ustream and there's,
there's no fucking way we could have
ever gotten someone to agree to let us
practice a TV show.
This is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna start off just fucking
around with boxes of shit behind me,
piled up on the desk and that eventually
we're going to move on to like try to
have like a real show,
like a desk and real microphones and the
sound is much better.
We got to like a top end MP,
three recorder and then the next thing
we got ustream producer.
We're going to have high def cameras in
here and eventually we're going to
figure out how to do it all through a
tri caster so that we can have a
background and we'll put a green screen
up behind us.
We never thought that this was going to
happen.
This is just a goof and and this.
This is not that.
This is any big deal like this could
have happened,
but it's this easy and this fun and
people would enjoy this much.
You could never.
I could have never done this on
television.
They would've never let me,
and if they did,
they would never let me just do it the
way we did it.
Just wing it and talk about whatever.
For the first fucking 10 weeks we didn't
even have plan what we're going to talk
about.
We would just get in there,
turn it on and just talk about it,
you know.
So I completely lost what the fuck I was
talking about.
I completely lost what I was saying.
My.
I know what my point is.
My point is that this is new TV and
you're right and it protects me really
if I do something like the flashlight or
any of the ridiculous should I do it
protects me from doing any dumb fear
factor type shit in the future.
It's so funny because there is a pretty
direct line on the old TV where the new
tvs mixing with the old TV right now.
I was watching family guy and the
episode involved at dog licking out a
baby's asshole,
but it was on the last episode had that,
uh,
were Brian.
The dog ate out steelies asshole and
cleaned shit office as,
how's that?
And we're talking about masturbating,
having a problem with masturbating.
Wow.
That's incredible.
I have to see that episode,
Dude.
It's the best episode download last
episode of family guy.
They're trapped in a bank,
a bank vault or something like that,
and it is so fucking ridiculous.
The shit that they get away with
unregular primetime television and we're
talking about fucking at rubber.
Your,
uh,
as successful as they are or successful
south park is,
you basically can do whatever the fuck
you want because people want to be on
your show,
you know,
advertisers rather,
right?
They want to advertise on your show and
your show is gigantic.
South Park has just got such all loyal
Legion of followers at this point in
time until the Mohammed thing.
They've pretty much got away with doing
like almost anything they wanted for a
long time.
That's crazy about the Mohammed that
mean because in New York City they just
captured that guy,
that bomber and there's a connection
that people are starting to make between
a Republican senator or something like
that said that they,
uh,
I think there might be a connection
between the two,
but they haven't proved anything yet.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
that's a good thing to speculate
automatically that be a connection.
But you know who the fuck knows yoder
was,
man,
what if listen man,
people,
people are that dumb.
There are people that really do believe
that you're not supposed to make fun of
them at all and if you do,
you're supposed to die like that.
They are the.
That's the worst example of human beings
in the world.
And the problem with the Middle East,
and this is what I've always talked
about,
I've talked about it as a joke in my
act,
but it really is kind of true.
One of the reasons why the there,
there are so arcane in their ways.
We don't try and adjust the sound.
One of the reasons why there are so
arcane in their ways is that that's
where culture like began.
The oldest known civilization that we
know of is Sumir and that's where Iraq
is.
So basically like the people that are
still in that area or like the townies
of the world.
I mean,
they're really stuck on some fucking
multifamily hundred year old trip and us
being in America,
and it's not that America is better than
other countries,
but the one advantage that America has
as it were the most recent country,
so we're all from somewhere that sucked.
Every one of us here is we came from
somewhere that sucked or answer says
came from somewhere that suck and they
congregate it to this one place to get
the most fresh idea supposedly to be the
most progressive because they're at the
furthest ahead of the curve,
but people in like the Middle East,
that's the furthest.
That's the beginning point of the curve.
Like do they really are the fucking
townies of the world and that's why the
problem with this fucking cartoon thing
is that these motherfuckers really do
believe that there's some magical
motherfucker that you're not supposed to
draw.
I mean,
it's,
it's bananas.
You know that that is the enemy of
evolution.
This ancient ideology,
this multipurpose fucking ridiculous
idea that somehow or another several
thousand years ago,
they had it wired.
They hadn't figured out back then,
even though they didn't know Jack Shit
about medicine,
about the constellations.
They didn't know anything,
but they had it wired.
They.
They knew.
They knew what was going on.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It's ridiculous.
The fact that there's people willing to
die for that,
that in 2010 that is still rocking.
It is amazing.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
Tom Cruise was the same way to do.
Personally.
I think that the scariest thing is not
even the Middle East.
I don't think the scariest thing in this
world is that ideology.
I think that's very scary,
but to me what's scarier is what's
happening in Mexico and the fact that
Mexico is connected to us and Mexico is
the middle of gigantic gang wars between
the police and these gang cartels that
have fucking billions of dollars.
These guys have insane amounts of money
because that's the only way you can make
money.
So it's basically like.
I mean,
that's not the only way you can make
money in Mexico.
So I what I'm saying,
I'm saying,
you know,
they're totally illegal to sell cocaine.
It has to be sold illegal.
You can't sell it legally.
You can't regulate it and tax it.
You can't do anything with it.
You have to sell it illegally.
So people are going to buy cocaine,
they're going to buy cocaine from Mexico
and there's,
someone's going to get that money.
Who the fuck's going to get that money?
Will these drug lords have all that
money and now they're more powerful than
the police and they've got US troops are
going in there now and fucking helping
out.
I mean,
it's bananas down there,
Dude.
There's fucking ward in the streets with
tanks with bananas and people are still
going there for vacations.
It's like the last spring break that was
still one of the hotspots for people to
go for spring break.
If they were Muslims,
we'd be fucked.
Okay.
The fact that they're Christians and
then on into blown themselves up for,
you know,
for Jesus,
they're,
they're into,
you know,
I mean what's going on is it's a lot of
money and a lot of influence and a lot
of people that get illegal money and
they're dominating the actual political
system over there and as many as they
try to raid,
there's so many more of them.
It's such a fucking hard fight because
they let them like,
dig in and get infested.
There's so many fucking gigantic cartels
with just tons and tons of money and
guns.
It's so frightening.
But if they like,
if they were the enemy,
if that was Muslim,
I mean if like,
if like Pakistan was right next door to
us and this shit was going down,
it would be even scarier.
You know?
It really would because for some reason
the Mexicans aren't blaming the
Americans.
It's really interesting.
It's like Mexican people are pretty
proud people and now they're not blaming
a lot of family here and that's fine.
They're not going to fuck with half of
their families.
It's also,
I mean it's really clear what happened.
They want to.
Mexico wanted to make drugs illegal,
they wanted to decriminalize it and make
them legal and make it so that people
can sell them and tax and mental and the
United States said no fucking way,
like no way and if you don't have laws
and you know you were involved in a
business like selling drugs,
you're going to have criminals because
even when you have laws,
we have things like pharmaceutical
companies.
Pharmaceutical companies are basically
legal drug dealers and they're dealing
shit that kills motherfuckers every day.
There's always people dropping off from
vicodin and percocet.
I remember when I got my nose fixed,
when I got my deviated septum operated
on,
the good doctor gave me to a value.
No,
it was a,
a vicodin and percocet.
He gave me a prescription for both and I
looked at him like,
man,
this stuff is bad for you.
Like how bad is this going to fucking
hurt?
It's going to hurt way more than it
hurts right now.
Like I'd rather just deal with it being
annoying.
Then get hooked on some crazy fucking
pharmaceutical pills that like an
addict.
You like what?
Like 30 percent of the time.
How many people get addicted to Vicodin?
Like did they think of those things out
like candy?
Well,
right after I decided not to accept the
prescription.
A study came out showing that the FDA
food and Drug Administration so was
there.
They're going to recommend like cutting
way back on prescriptions and they like
recommend that doctors did not prescribe
them because of liver damage and because
of addiction I have probably for half
full bottles of magnum laying around
just from going to the dentist.
They talked to you sometimes.
Do they talk to you that vitamin
bottles?
Only when I sleep,
like in the middle of the night I wake
up and you're combing my hair and go,
Geez,
you really stressed right now.
You feel better.
Actually I hate Mike.
Shoe me up,
man.
I hate fighting.
I hate feeling.
I just feel gross when I do like it and
I've only done vicodin once.
When I had my first knee operation,
I've had three knee operations,
two acl reconstructions,
one meniscus surgery,
and uh,
the first time I had the acl done it was
pretty painful because they did what's
called a Patella tendon graft,
a scar that goes from here to here.
And what they do is they take a chunk of
bone out of your knee and a chunk of
bone out of your Shin and they cut this
big tendon.
This is one of the,
they cut a slice of it off with the bone
and then they open you up like a fish
and they drill it in place.
So they take this tendon and they make
it smaller to make you a fake tendon for
the acl.
And it's apparently it was supposedly
like physically stronger than the
original acl.
But the point is you're,
you got holes in your bones and screws
and your bones and it hurts like a bitch
when you get up,
especially when you're sitting down and
then you get up.
It's way more pain.
I have the other one done with a
cadaver,
so I got a dead dudes.
Shit in this knee,
but the one with the acl where they do
the surgery with the ticket off the bone
is way,
way,
way more painful.
You get up from the couch and be like
watching TV and it was just like hot
lava,
just hot lead.
Just going right into my bones.
It was so fucking painful and I took a
vicodin.
That was the only time I ever took one
and I felt so stupid.
Yeah,
just so drugged and my jaw was slack and
I was watching TV and I thought to
myself while it was under it,
I was like,
I will never take this dumb shit again.
This stuff's terrible.
Yeah,
so we'd have some people are the exact
opposite.
They'll give you 20 bucks for awakening.
Well,
W w what basically we're trying to say
is there's no fucking difference between
vicodins inheritance.
Heroin and Oxycontin and heroin are
really the same thing.
There's no fucking difference between
pharmaceutical companies and drug
dealers.
The only difference is that drug dealers
don't have to.
They don't have to work within the law.
The pharmaceutical companies,
they have to bribe politicians.
They have to.
They have to wax doctors,
you know what to do with doctors.
They take everybody out to dinner.
Mrs Rogan is,
her mom is a nurse and I'm the.
She's a.
She works with these pharmaceutical
companies,
these nurses,
they don't make much money and they
don't get to go out to fancy dinners
where the pharmaceutical companies come
along and say,
hey,
Viagara is going to take us out on a
nice dinner and they all get to go to a
nice restaurant and have a nice meal and
it's all on these pharmaceutical
companies.
They pay for the drinks,
they pay for everything and so these
people are more likely to talk nice
about their pharmaceuticals,
so they prescribe them more.
You know what's fucked up about that is
I've thought about that also when I go
to the doc.
The other is that the doctor review.
It was a poor example because that's a
good one.
Right.
I went to the doctor's the other day for
acid reflux because sometimes after eat
like too much caffeine,
onions or a drink too much.
I kind of have feel like an acid coming
up from my throat.
It makes my throat feel tight and all
this other stuff.
I had this for a long time.
I've had it for a while,
so finally went to the doctor,
the ODA digestive doctor,
and I told him everything I had and then
he's like,
oh,
let me give you some samples.
He gave me a garbage bag,
almost full of the sample was called the
blue pill.com.
I don't remember what the name of it,
but was the blue pill.com
or something that.
And I'm thinking,
you know what,
I wonder if this is even the best thing
I could be taking right now or if this
guy just got paid to get me a bottle and
because he gave me like 20 bottles of
samples and coupons and books and it's
like.
And I,
I take it and I'm like,
yeah,
I guess that kind of is better,
but I don't know if I'm just tricking
myself or if I have to go back there,
make a second appointment,
you know,
just to be like,
look,
whatever you gave me,
that's bullshit.
We know for sure the doctors are
influenced by pharmaceutical.
You know,
they give them money,
they get money for.
They were getting,
I don't know if it's still true,
it's still legal in or if there's
different states have different laws.
I don't know how it all works,
but from what I understand,
doctors have been busted where they're
getting a percentage of the amount of
sales that they have.
Like say if they sell,
you know,
x amount of volumes,
they get a kickback from the
pharmaceutical company.
That should absolutely be illegal.
I mean that's
crazy.
And that's what an analyst that's
hopefully technology helps that done.
So when they tried to prescribe
something like a million topics come
from text to your phone and you go,
actually no,
I want to take this one.
This one's better,
you know like yeah,
an iphone apps.
It tells you,
your doctors trying to get you to turn
it,
you turned it on and when the doctor not
trying to shit on doctors anything,
then that's.
The whole system is fucked up.
And when you're a doctor and you're
struggling to get along and you have to
pay an insane amount of malpractice
insurance,
malpractice insurance for doctors has
goddamn brutal.
And then you have all these assholes
that want to sue you for fucking
nothing,
for no reason for shit getting wrong,
for you.
Getting an affection for things that are
totally unavoidable.
And I'm not saying the doctors perfect,
but you know,
it's hard for doctors,
their medical bills or fucking or
medical school bills are gigantic.
They're fucking huge.
And then all of a sudden some
pharmaceutical company comes along and
says,
Hey,
you know,
you're,
you're still helping all these people.
You're still doing great thing.
We just would love it if you would tell
them,
you know,
Take Vioxx if you have arthritis.
So these doctors say,
yeah,
I could do that and we'll,
we'll,
we'll be in on a deal with you guys.
You can buy it,
you know,
we'll give you a share in the company
will give you a certain percentage for
every Vioxx bottle you sell.
We'll give you x percent.
And so they don't think they're doing
anything wrong.
Vioxx is something that was created to
help people.
This person has a pain,
I'll give them this,
it'll help their pain and I'll profit in
it and they don't even think it's a bad
thing.
And then next thing you know that
they're prescribing it way more than
they did before,
especially like nutty pills or you talk
to like there's been many studies done
on people who take on to have a presence
and how,
uh,
people have gone to a psychiatrist just
for experimentation purposes just to
write stories on it and just said,
hey,
you know,
I'm just having trouble sleeping.
I feel shitty all day.
I don't know what to do here.
Take this.
Bam.
It's like that simple of Zoloft and
you'll feel better,
right?
Like they're just dishing it out.
Try this for a little bit and tell us
how you feel like,
Whoa,
we're fucking with human neurochemistry
and we're allowing these heartless
pharmaceutical companies to do it.
You can't do that,
man.
There's got to be more oversight.
I know there's a lot of money in
involved in pharmaceuticals and I know
that there's a lot of pharmaceuticals
that do a lot of good for a lot of
people.
Not saying there's anything bad about
it,
but there's got to be way more oversight
because they have so much shit out there
that you can get addicted to.
There's so much that will fuck your life
up and it's readily available.
Oxycontin's fucking percosets.
Volume's vicodins.
Those,
those fucking things will crush you and
somehow or another,
those guys are doing something that's
way more acceptable than some of
themselves.
Pot or coke or Fox or rubber or vagina
or vagina looked at as heroes,
doctors and staff,
but yet if you talk about this book,
doctors are heroes.
Man,
the doctors at a fixed me up,
I'm in forever in their debt.
The guy who fixed my nose,
the guys who fixed my knees,
you know,
if it wasn't for them,
I knows what suck and I wouldn't be able
to walk that good.
You know what I mean?
Doctors are fucking awesome.
I'm not saying that.
I'm just saying we live in this
ridiculous state of a poc resy because
there's certain drugs that we make
illegal.
You aren't supposed to have them.
It's not that you can get them
prescribed if you need them or they can,
you know,
monitor,
you know you're not allowed to.
Big Daddy who knows more than you,
tells you that if you're with this drug,
this drug,
we're going to lock you in a cage like
what the fuck?
Why is that?
Is that set up so that the people who
really appreciate and recognize the
merits and the psychedelic drugs rise up
so that they realize they have to
literally overthrow the,
the culture,
the way of thinking.
They have to not overthrow rather,
but overturn the way,
the way the culture accepts drugs
because that's the only thing that seems
to make sense.
All the beneficial ones are illegal.
You don't ever hear about someone
talking to you about they did value them
and they.
They just really had this life changing
experience and learn to love everyone.
No,
you don't have that fucking on valium.
I felt connected to the universe and I
realized that I'm just a part of a never
ending process in my biology is trying
to hold onto everything and that's where
the insecurity comes from.
You know?
No,
you don't get that from fucking value.
Okay.
You get that from mushrooms and
mushrooms grow outside and if they catch
you with them,
they put you in a cage.
If they come by your fucking house and
you have mushrooms growing on your car
under your tree,
in your backyard,
they are legally allowed to lock you in
a box.
They can take you and arrest you.
That's fucking bananas.
Bananas and that are enforcing our
ridiculous thinking on the Mexican
people is why those drug cartels got
into power.
Is that a conspiracy theory perhaps?
Is that a little bit of Tinfoil hat
perhaps?
Yeah,
maybe,
but you know,
some of that tin foil hat shit is on the
money and I,
I think it is with this,
we're live right next to a country
that's involved in a way more deadly war
than the one going on in Afghanistan or
going on in Iraq.
Both of them combined.
Can't even touch the body counts that
are happening in Mexico right next door.
They're killing motherfuckers.
They're going crazy over there,
dude,
and you can get there by walking.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
we're all invested in Afghanistan and
securing Afghanistan.
Meanwhile,
we live right next to a fucking third
world country.
We are connected to them with an
invisible line and they're involved in
the bloodiest pharmaceutical war that's
ever been fought in the history of this
earth,
the illegal pharmaceutical war.
They're finding it with God damn tanks.
They're fighting a pharmaceutical war
with tanks and that's what the war is
the worst.
Who gets to sell your shit?
Is it going to be people that have no
law whatsoever or is it going to be
people that have laws and if you say
it's going to be people that have laws
and that the other stuff,
you're not going to allow,
well then someone's gonna sell that
other stuff cause he's a goddamn demand
for it.
It sits dangerous everywhere that.
Did you hear about this?
A West Hollywood like yesterday or
something like that.
A woman walks into target at West
Hollywood.
I just started fucking stabbing or
shooting people,
I think shooting people,
shop for people and finally was taken
down by you.
Got to do a google.
This is the age of the Internet side.
You can't be used in like 1984 type
storytelling skills.
We'll give you a why look us up,
give some facts about target.
Target is an awesome place if you want
to buy some shit and they usually have
it there.
However,
target will not carry the rubber pussy.
No target frowns upon the rubber pussy.
They're not stabs for people in a so it
is stabbing in West Hollywood.
Uh,
she's 34 years old.
Enter the store.
Attack shoppers with a butcher knife,
a steak knife and off duty.
La County Sheriff,
deputy and store security guards
apprehended her.
Thank God those guys were there.
Thank God someone so fucking balls.
I hope they brain that bitch.
When they took her out,
they should have just shoved that
fucking knife right into our heart.
You know,
you're in the middle of a battle,
a knife battle with a knife wielding
assailant.
You should just stick that fucking thing
right in neck.
Wow.
She was yelling,
I'm bipolar.
There's no witness protection program.
Oh God.
See?
At that point we have to know when to
kill people.
We really do.
You can't bring that person back and
reintroduce them to society.
This life is short and you have fucked
it up so bad.
There's just no way of coming back from
that.
We just got to start from scratch and it
sends a message to all the other people
out there thinking about going nutty.
Don't go that nutty.
All right.
Stop.
They'll go running into target and
fucking stabbing people.
We're not going to allow that shit.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
we're so goddamn tolerant of fucking
loonies to kill him.
Yeah.
Have you seen those back?
I think I talked about this,
talked about it the other day when we
were talking to the fleshlight dude does
it the new,
the new,
uh,
piercings where they have a up and down
your back.
They have hoops and then they take laces
and go back and forth,
like it's a dress and I tie bows and
stuff with it.
I was thinking,
you know how fucking crazy is that?
Even piercings are crazy.
I remember back in the day it was left
hoop,
right hoop,
you know,
that was the whigs and one eyebrow
eyebrow eyebrow.
And it moved on the belly button and
then like some crazy girls got nipples
and clits.
Now they're fucking making clothes out
of your skin.
I think you should probably talk to that
microphone more.
Put the pumped up.
Pick it up.
Yeah,
but it's getting to the point where now
it's like like laces back and forth and
like you're.
You're making skin dresses.
That's how crazy piercing is.
Yeah.
What he's talking about as a series of
loops that these women are putting on
their bodies and their back and they
make it like shoelaces.
Yeah.
Fucking.
It's the trippiest thing ever.
When you see someone that's a girl
doesn't give a fuck,
right?
Yeah.
There was a blank.
If you fuck her in the ass,
she'll be like,
what?
There was a girl standing outside of my
grocery store trying to do Greenpeace,
whatever that shit is because she had
that whole thing up and down with a bra
on.
Do you
think that that's the message that the
message is that they're just.
They can take all sorts of crazy pain.
That's the sexiness of the message that
our people are just getting weird about
skin.
Yeah,
but does that maybe the sexiness of the.
What it is,
is that you know,
what you're doing is you're taking a
lust to the next level because
everything has got to go to the next
level now because we have this crazy
access to information,
you know,
like people are fucking way different
than they fucked.
Like in the 19 seventies,
you know,
no one is accepting,
lights out,
you know,
just fucking and no,
no dirty talk.
No nothing.
Missionary Style Rollover Kiska and I go
to sleep.
No one is accepting that everyone's
going [inaudible] style and this is all
because of the Internet because
pornography has changed the way people
look at sex and you know what they're
talking about.
A lot of people are talking about
there's a problem with young girls right
now getting all sorts of problems with
their bubbles because they're having but
sex like,
hey,
early and all the time.
Yeah,
there's going to be a lot of 30 year old
women in a couple years from now with
that.
Yeah.
The diapers on and that's gonna be the
fashion I fastened with your pamper.
Oh my God.
No,
you know it's going to be.
The big operation is not going to be
botox.
It's going to be getting your butthole
tightening,
get your butthole brought back to
reality and like a filter for awhile.
You're going to have to use a colostomy
bag for a little while until your
butthole gets recovered from the
surgery.
That's Shit's real,
man.
That's.
That's one of these people doing.
They're their.
You know what they're doing.
They're there.
They're getting there.
They're getting everything to the
highest level possible.
That's what these piercings are about.
That's what guys think.
Girls who were tattooed up or sexy,
what's sexy about tattoos?
If you have tattoos,
you know how much fucking pain it
causes.
It's so God damn painful,
so you see someone with tattoos,
you're like,
that's someone who doesn't give a fuck,
you know,
and that's the sexiness of it,
but shit,
we're word bananas,
man.
Our society is going in a very,
very,
very strange direction.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
It's the,
the age of information is not
necessarily aiding it entirely because
people aren't necessarily using the
information on the Internet to make an
objective opinion.
They're usually trying to find stuff
that reinforces their own current
opinion.
It's a very tempting thing.
You know,
you've got to look at like,
like w with ideas in the Internet.
You got to look at both sides of it,
but a lot of people aren't.
So it's like almost helping retards be
retarded if they can find other sites
that say the earth is flat and dinosaurs
lived with people 6,000
years ago,
as long as you can.
You can find plenty of sites.
If you look around and tells you that
evolution is retarded,
you could have plenty of science that
we'll have guys who are doctors and
they're scientists and they are telling
me they're obviously crazy,
but they're telling people that the
earth is only 6,000
years old and carbon dating is not real
and that evolution is a myth and that,
you know,
we had to come from somewhere so there
has to be a god and that,
you know,
the Bible is,
can prove the Bible mathematically and
they start talking talk and these are
doctors and scientists.
So if you just look for them,
you'll,
you'll decide on their point of view,
you know,
I mean if you just look at any one side
of any issue you can,
you can get your answers reinforced.
So the problem with that is people are
just getting their answers reinforced or
questions rather reinforced there.
They're not necessarily like learning,
you know,
they're finding other retards,
your setup websites that confirmed
they're retarded ideas and all that.
That's kind of a little bit of a
problem.
That's one problem with the Internet.
You know,
the other part of it is just
magnificent.
The other part of it is people who are
open minded who are really using it,
it's this crazy network of information
and they're really learning like at this
incredible exponentially expanding rate.
Like we're learning shit and we're so
much more aware of shit than our parents
were.
Were so much more aware of information.
There's so much more shit going on that
you have to store in your head.
I mean it's the one I talked to my mom
about like the world,
like what's going on in the world.
It's,
I feel like I'm talking to my daughter.
I mean it's like it's,
you know,
there's,
there's a level of understanding that
our civilization or are.
I'm a generation has reached that really
hasn't been reached before.
Is that just an age thing?
No,
no.
It's the,
it's the Internet man.
The Internet.
Yeah.
I mean it's acceleration.
I mean,
I think our parents were smarter than
their parents and their parents were
smarter than their parents and you know,
it's always been that way that we evolve
and as we evolve,
we get brighter.
And you can see that in culture,
you can see that in like the movies that
use,
they used to watch the 19 forties,
they're fucking horrible.
I mean,
they're way worse than the right.
It doesn't even have to be the 1940 the
other day.
I watched a reality bites.
I don't know if you remember that movie
had a,
uh,
what's his name?
Ben Stiller.
Janeane Garofalo had all these famous
people are awesome.
Sounds.
What was the other one that you.
You're telling me that you made your
girl watch you.
You thought it was an awesome movie at
the time,
but it was fucking terrible and she was
mad at you.
What was that?
Oh,
can't buy me love.
But Reality Bites don't you?
The dream big dream is in it.
And he used to mow lawns and he paid the
money bag.
All those bras delivering pizzas.
And that's the same one.
No one paid the most popular girl to be
his girlfriend for a week.
And then he became too popular and then
she's still cranberry juice on a dress
today.
But I watched that the other day.
It was awful.
But reality bites,
horrible,
like really uncomfortable to watch and
then.
But the worst disturbing thing is I used
to have a crush on Janeane Garofalo back
in that time period.
I thought she was like,
oh,
she's a hot comic girl.
She's so high.
I looked at that movie,
almost puked because how ugly she was.
Now I want to know what the fuck.
Don't be rude.
That's rude.
You're being rude in a movie character
and the character in that movie with
Abby,
you used to have different tastes.
Now you're into like the porn star.
Look,
that's all cool.
That's all cool.
You know?
But back then that's what it is.
Everybody has a look and he watched the
movie.
You could see the line where we're
making it up.
That's ridiculous.
Listen,
that's not what's important.
What's important is the evolution of
culture.
What's important in this conversation is
not your fucking weird thing.
Which my.
I'm just saying I evolved.
That movie to me is like I watched
altered states.
It was terrible,
right?
Ultra stays totally.
Just not home.
Hold
up.
I mean,
to me,
that movie changed my life because
that's the movie that got me into the
isolation tanks.
If it wasn't for altered states,
I probably never would have a tank in my
basement and when that tank in my
basement has changed the way I look at
the world,
that thing is like my reset button.
Whenever I got anything that's fucking
with my hand,
that tank kicks me the real deal.
Every time.
It's like my guidebook.
It's like literally to me,
my isolation tank.
He's like my connection to the spirit
world.
It's like my spirit guide.
It sounds completely retarded and gay
and it sounds new agey,
but that's what it feels like when I get
in there and I just zone.
I just disappear.
My body disappears when my mind has no
sensory input.
What?
I'm just floating through space in that
tank.
I get truth.
I get straight truth about everything
I've ever done about anything that I've
ever done where I was the Douche bag.
Anything that I've ever watched where
you know,
I,
I can rewatch like things that have
happened in my life and see where I've
personally made mistakes,
things that I've done well,
things that I could have avoided,
reasons why people are upset at me,
like everything you kicks you and then
it kicks me everything about what am I
doing wrong in my personal life?
What am I doing wrong in my career?
What am I doing wrong in my comedy?
What am I doing wrong in my writing?
Here's what you could eliminate.
Here's what you can do better.
Almost never like it's never appraising
thing.
It's always like a ruthless
self-examination experience.
It's never like a experience like,
yeah,
I'm fucking awesome here.
I'm in the water.
Never.
It's almost always uncomfortable,
but after you get out of it,
man,
you have a new found appreciation and
respect for life,
you know,
and that,
that experience would not have happened
if I didn't watch that movie.
Altered states and get,
get confused.
Meanwhile watched it.
I couldn't even watch the whole movie.
I shut it off.
It was a piece of shit.
Those old movies just don't hold up like
etc.
I watched that the other day and you
remember when it was like,
I could believe this is an alien I saw
the other day and he's like,
ha,
I can stop any rocks when he stops on my
rocking.
It's so bad.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
The technology available today,
a random dude with a pc who knows how to
encode three d animation.
he could make something its own computer
and literally have a texture to it and
everything.
It will be way better than 18.
Imagine what you could do that with
avatar graphics.
Oh my god.
It's going to happen.
Why does that?
Would that be 15 years,
15 years,
years,
15 years?
Shit is happening so quickly,
man.
Well,
with the internet,
with the level of complexity that they
can pull off and animation now is just
astounding.
I mean,
avatar still looked a little off,
but the reason why they got away with it
looking a little off is that they used
monsters and shit that you don't know in
real life.
so you know,
you're looking at it and you go,
oh,
it's fake.
You can't tell it's fake.
But like you've watched like I am
legend,
I am.
Legend is the shit.
But when they had those lions,
you like,
get the fuck out of here.
Those lines look so bad here.
They're making a sequel to that have so
good.
I love that.
I love that movie.
That movie was fun.
And uh,
the um,
in the,
in the scene where he shoots the lion or
he shoot,
he's going to shoot a deer and align it
takes out the deer.
It looks so bad.
It looks so corny and fake.
It's so.
It should be totally unacceptable.
Like they really should have to film in
another way,
but you should have to do it in the
where I can't see it when it happened so
quickly.
But what you show me is just dog shit
for a movie that's that powerful.
They can't totally recreate real life.
And because of that,
they can't totally recreate people yet,
but they can really recreate monster
shit that they make up.
They can make shit that they invent.
Look fucking amazing.
Like king kong,
king kong.
That was awesome.
I just saw that the other day also and
that was still looks good,
dude.
I don't even watch that movie.
You know what I do with that movie?
I turned it on to the scene where king
kong's fucking shit up.
He jack off.
I almost do.
I scratch my chest.
Fucking crazy footage.
If you watching king kong by start
flooding.
I've always been obsessed with primates.
I have a giant poster.
King kong,
it's like 12 feet tall.
My flasHlights around like fucking apes.
I have just a smidgen more monkey in me
than the average person.
I feel.
I feel very connected to the monkeys.
I get angry when I go to the zoo and I
see the monkeys in the cage.
I always want to let him out.
It's always been like that little kid
being curious.
George fan,
sIcilian man.
Those monkeys.
they're way closer to monkeys and
regular people.
There's.
There's something about my.
My ancestors,
the way they used to yell at each other.
It's just like going to the fucking
chimps.
My grandmother used to fucking scream at
my grandfather.
She didn't give a fuck that I was there.
She didn't give a fuck that I was three
or four or whatever the fuck I was.
I'd be standing right next to her.
She and my grandfather.
My grandmother was always late for
everything.
My grandmother was crazy.
She,
my grandmother did time.
Okay.
So crazy.
My grandma,
my grandmother worked for the mom and
she didn't come.
That's crazy.
And my grandmother's bananas,
but she would fucking screen.
My grandfather's name was joe.
Her name was jo.
She would fucking scream at him and he
would have to eat it.
You're like a monkey.
I wasn't in the family.
My family was in the line
cage at the zoo.
What's up guys?
Yeah,
you seem like a lion.
I had to
describe you.
You know what?
What can brian was an animal?
What would it be?
Be?
What are you?
What's your son?
Leah?
Yardley.
That's right.
Don't have a monkey sign.
If they had a monkey sound,
I'm sure I'd be here a tiger.
Do you get upset when you go to the zoo?
Does that bother you?
It doesn't surprise me fucking crap.
More lIke,
wow,
tiger.
I don't advise me.
I'm just not that deep.
I don't care about the dumb animals.
Like I don't freak out when I see a
walrus.
Fuck a wall ball.
We're kIss my ass.
Give a fuck about you.
You're just dumb.
You know?
What are you doing?
I don't want to kill you.
I don't want to hurt you.
I don't want to cause you pain for no
reason,
but I don't give a fuck about you.
When's your movies?
Zookeeper coming out.
It's not my movie.
Your movie's Kevin James movie,
bro.
And it comes out in october,
october.
Have you seen a preview?
I've seen little clips where I had to do
a voiceover shit.
It's going to be fun.
Yeah,
it's a funny movie.
Kevin's hilarious.
He's a very funny guy.
He's awesome at that.
That whole physical comedy thing and
doing it with all these animated animals
and the animated animals.
Pretty fucking dope.
Yeah.
They just,
they just changed their mouths and make
their mouths move.
They're like real animals.
They have to train real animals,
do certain things,
and then they like add animation to it,
you know,
and then they have like one guy in a
monkey suit that one guy that's really
funny,
walked into a car,
accidentally knocked himself out.
It was really fucked up,
you know,
because he,
he hit the thing hard.
He rented the door,
this car and just fell over our cold.
Wow.
You didn't see a comment and he walked
right into a door.
This duck man,
man,
stop man.
A fucking savages.
These guys are nuts,
man.
The dude that I met on fear factor and
the dudes that I've worked with,
especially the guys on this,
a zookeeper movie,
[inaudible],
there was a lot of crazy stunts.
I,
I crashed a bike.
I wasn't supposed to be doing my own
stunts,
but I had this bike scene with me and
kevin were.
I'm chAsing them and I'm yelling at him,
trying to reach them.
I crashed my bike three or four hard
times.
Hard times.
One way I go over the handlebars.
Are you dating to the concrete dude?
I went over the bars.
I grabbed the front brake accidentally
in squeeze it too hard and I just went
over the top.
That was only one hand in it because I
was trying to grab him.
JusT improvising a scene.
Dude.
I launched myself,
but somehow or another I was fine.
Like somehow or another I this,
the,
the whatever,
the clear headedness or the,
you know,
the peace of mind to gather myself.
No,
I knew I was going over this and just
land correctly enrolled or something,
something.
I got lucky all the time.
The only thing I did,
I got a scratch on my shin,
but dude,
that crashed hard like four times.
I did the crash recently that it could
have easily broken a wrist or something.
There's was one time when I went down
where it was pretty fucking hard.
I went over the handlebars and I got
ahold of.
I hit the ground first with my hands and
then my face,
my chin hit the ground,
but I absorbed it and I pulled back
enough.
It was like just enough level headedness
where I did.
I wound up not because of jujitsu,
I'm always fallen.
You're always rolling with shit.
You get comfortable with that.
Like here's the round.
It's like it's normal.
It's a normal feeling,
but dude,
I kind of got fucked up.
I could have lost some teeth
for sure.
Yeah,
I,
I just got a bike recently and I did the
same thing.
I went over my handlebars because I hit
a curb.
It was dark out and I hit a curb and it
didn't like pop over.
It just went straight down for a second
and I flipped over my bike and I felt
like my teeth.
I'm like,
oh my god,
that's the first thing I do is grab my
teeth,
but I landed okay.
But I was like,
I could have died right there.
Yeah,
man,
that's some scary shit.
Bicycles are fucking scary when you're
fallen,
man.
I just read some article about some
woman who just got paralyzed from a
horse racing horse jumping same as
christopher reeve did,
jumping over hurdles and shit like that.
That's some scary shit,
dude.
You don't need to be doing that.
People in,
you know,
taking it from a guy who was involved in
the ufc does jujitsu.
It sounds ridiculous.
But jujitsu,
if you,
if you trust your partners,
you pretty safe that.
I mean I'm doing it all the time and
I've only been injured a few times and
one of the injuries was an old injury.
You know,
I had one acl and meniscus tear from my
old taekwondo days and that one
re-injured first in jujitsu and then I,
I
injured the other leg,
but that's over fucking.
I've been doing it now for 14 years.
That's a long ass time.
You not only have a few minor injuries
and to roll like all the time because
most of the time you're rolling with
dudes you can trust and you know you're
not going to fucking dump each other on
each other's heads.
You're not gonna.
You're not going to hurt each other if
you don't have to.
Like when you get an armbar stop me back
off before you know,
you know,
you know when a dude is got you know,
you don't hurt each other so that you
could trust people.
Well,
you can't trust a fucking Horse.
You can't trust a horse.
If the horse is decides,
fuck this.
It just digs those legs in.
You're done sign.
You're going to go flying.
You're.
You're on a giant,
super powerful animal and animal that's
so strong.
It can run like what?
Fifty miles an hour with a person on its
back.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You're going to go off like a pillow.
You're just going to go flying off.
You're not even going to believe how
light you feel.
That horse just stops and just throws
his muscular fucking shoulders up into
it.
You just launched like you're on a
spring head first,
right into the dirt.
Snap your neck.
How cool would it be?
none of us had cars because gas went out
and we all had to get horses.
We all had our own horse and then like
every time we went,
hung out.
We all had her horses together to be
friends with their horse.
Breaks his leg.
You to shoot him in the head.
I know.
Think that's terrible.
Yeah,
but then we'll get into horse or two of
her friends.
Horses would mate and have a baby horse.
It'd be cool just to have your own
horse.
Brian,
where's into?
She definitely had one extra hit I think
should not have had that third hit.
I think it's cool that I live in an
equestrian district where it'd be nice
if you're with the horse and you treated
it very well from the time it was young,
so you had an awesome relationship with
the horse.
Right.
But that's not always going to be the
case and it's going to be like you go to
a dog park with your dog.
There's always gonna be some douche bag
with his fucking dog that wants a bite.
Everybody's dog,
you know.
And that's gonna be what it's going to
be like with horses.
My other two can't trust people to raise
the horses correctly.
So you're gonna have a bunch of horses
out there that are douchebag horses.
They're going to get mad at your horses.
You're gonna have douchebag.
Gang wars.
Awesome.
This is the most ridiculous conversation
to have a horse.
What else,
brian?
Well,
I was shooting for real money.
Wouldn't you get.
I'd get a pony when,
if I can't get a pegasus,
what if we run out of oil or if we run
out of golf?
Can we all go back to that?
That'd be crazy.
If you had to go back to the board.
It's really ridiculous how short a
period of time.
I put this on my twitter this week.
Go just thinking about it.
How nutty it is that 200 years ago,
the fastest way to get around was on the
back of an animal.
Right?
Two hundred years ago.
That's so funny to think about it.
And there was no photographs in the best
way to get an image of someone was to
draw them 200 years ago.
No,
that's nothing.
That's um,
a blink in time.
Jesus christ.
And it's all because of technology and
an oil.
Unfortunately.
It's all because of oil.
All the plastic,
all the shit we use.
I mean,
how is oil
like embedded in our life?
It's totally,
it's the main thing for almost all the
words for religion and oil together.
Yeah.
Well
I believe that religion and oil are
stuffed in together,
you know,
on purpose.
Just to make it easier to control the
oil,
you know,
whether or not that's true,
I mean the,
you know,
the idea that the cia is involved and
all these,
you know,
secret shadow government organizations
are involved in creating drama and
turmoil so that we always have an enemy
over there and that's a very real
theory.
And,
and you know,
if you talk to people who understand,
you know,
how the United States is involved in
other countries and how we do sell arms
to people like Iran and Iraq and we do
provide them with weapons and we played
both sides of the fence will provide
their enemy was shit too.
And we create,
we create drama,
you know,
this weekend go in there and cleaned it
up.
We should find a way to make money off
of religion oil combining the two like
jesus oil
in the oil business or all the people
that are supporting the conservative.
Right?
But at this point,
I think the concern that I think
everybody's involved,
you know,
I don't think it's just the
conservatives.
I don't think it's just the republicans.
The democrats are just as like,
I mean,
I believe obama was in favor of offshore
drilling,
you know,
I think there was so much pressure that
we need to relieve ourselves of the,
uh,
the need for foreign oil that they,
that they were in support of it.
I think everybody was of it.
Look,
it seemed like a great idea.
I was,
I mean,
I thought it was a good idea.
I'm like,
if they don't spill that shit and it
doesn't seem like they do very often.
I was like,
well,
hey,
if they know what they're doing,
that's the problem.
If they know what they're doing.
So I was in favor of it too until I saw
this and I was like,
okay,
this is crazy.
I got it.
No,
that this could happen.
I thought that if something breaks you
just shut it off.
You know,
I thought like you have some sort of a
fail safe.
Like I can't believe they had no backup
plan.
Like there's,
they don't know the exact estimate,
but one of the estimates is 40,000.
You're talking about 40,000
gallons a day.
That's insane.
Yeah.
think of how many,
how much oil that is.
Well,
I think have a big.
The ocean is,
so I've heard hundreds of thousands.
I've heard a million gallons a day.
I've heard all these different efforts
for hundred thousand,
but even if it's a thousand gallons of
oil a day even that.
Have you seen the slIck,
the slickest gigantic,
pretty fun green.
You can see it with a satellite.
I hate seeing the animals that they're
like cleaning off their phones is and
stuff like that.
Well,
the one of the ways that people describe
me and they're saying that it could be
apocalyptic,
like that was the language that they
use.
I'll talk elliptic apocalyptic.
It just sells more tee shirts.
Joe,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
I don't know dude.
It's,
it seems pretty.
Look at.
Look at,
um,
we're looking at images right now and
you can't see because you're not here,
but the streak is jai fucking qinetiq.
Okay.
Forty 2000 gallons of oil per day.
That's what these people are saying.
I mean,
who knows if they're right.
nobody's down there with the fucking a
measuring spoon.
MeasurIng,
We've been
talking about nobody's down there
measuring for real,
but it is an insane amount of oil and
it's leaking out every day and they
don't know exactly how they're going to
stop it and I heard someone last night,
but this is a dude in jujitsu class,
so who knows if he was telling me the
truth,
it could have been just talking out of
his ass,
but he was saying that they could stop
the oil,
but the way they would have to stop it
is blow up the.
Well they would have to blow it up and
if they did that the oil was stopped but
then they'd be fucked because they don't
want to do that because they have this
well down there.
They want to protect and they want to be
able to turn it back on again
eventually.
If that's true,
that's insane.
If there really is a fix and I have to
do is blow it up and they're worried
becAuse this,
this company wants to,
you know,
continue to pump oil out of there like
you.
Number one is you've got to stop what
you're doing.
You gotta stop oil coming out,
you know,
did you build the build the.
Well,
you built it right?
You built it.
He going to have to build a new one.
Okay.
You can't salvage the parts of this
while it's bleeding oil into the ocean.
I mean that's bananas.
Like if there really is a fix and the
fix involves them destroying the whole
thing,
you got to destroy the whole thing first
and then rebuild it.
I don't care how many years it takes to
make one of those things.
It doesn't.
That doesn't mean think how many years
is going to take to clean up?
What the fuck he did?
can't you just get a ship of cat litter
and put it on it?
Isn't that what you do in the garage?
Cat litter,
just clung to it.
It all.
YOu've used poor bags of it would make
these big gelatinous cat litter and oil
glob boulders that'd be sitting on the
bottom of the ocean floor and they would
just scoop them up.
I'm up.
I'm up like one of those cat more sense
than what they're doinG now.
Well,
they're not doing anything now.
They,
they've,
they've trIed to stop it,
they've cut it back a little bit
apparently supposedly from the most
recent reports,
but as far as getting it stopped or even
under control,
if you're not even close,
they could be a week away from doing
something,
you know,
they're talking about putting some kind
of giant dome over it.
I mean,
the whole thing is.
See,
that's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Superman movie.
If it Works in the garage or [inaudible]
o'shea,
it's fucking bananas.
The whole thing has bananas.
It's literally going to kill everything
in that area.
I mean there's the those slick.
I mean I'm looking at the images when
they show them to you online and it
doesn't seem real.
That doesn't seem crazy.
Does.
It literally doesn't seem real.
Look at this.
There's images.
If you go to earth observatory.nasa.gov,
you know,
you could just throw that picture and
you ustream producer and show everybody
right now if I can.
Yeah,
I don't do that.
Save it on your desktop and then just
throw it in there.
God damn brian,
you're so smart.
Blank image
slick.
Put that on my desktop
and now I'm going to ustream producer
and I just dragged it in.
This is not interesting at all or
listening online.
How do I do this?
I think you add pictures.
Here Was this picture,
but they're open image image file.
That's open video file.
I think you clicked on open image file.
Let's go down to your desktop
slick.
So
let's say this works.
What we did is we just start.
Yeah,
there we go.
We just started using this thing called
a ustream producer and the reason why.
So now you can see these ustream video
podcasts on your iphone and your ipad.
You fucking junkies,
you visual junkies.
but look at that god damn slick.
If you're looking at this on ustream,
if you're not an you're on itunes,
check this out.
When you get home,
go,
uh,
go google it.
Go to the nasa site and you see the size
of this fucking oil slick on,
on a satellite image.
And it's bananas.
It's really hard to grasp.
It's so big and it's just nonstop and
they don't even have it under control
and it's just pumping oil.
And I don't know how the fuck they're
going to.
I don't know how they're going to fix
that shit.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't think they know either,
man.
Don't think they know my ad.
Live shot and this action.
See now in the future you can just keep.
That's pretty dope man.
Powerful producer software.
Powerful.
Nice.
So,
uh,
you know,
until we get off fossil fuels,
we're never going to be able to avoid
catastrophes that happen when,
when oil spills,
there was another one that just happened
and where a m and a
laca straight an oil tanker exploded.
And this was yesterday
in
peck and baroo.
I don't know where that is.
A crude oil tanker was reported to have
exploded.
Like they fucking explode.
That shit's flammable,
you know?
I mean,
you can't get away from that.
We have to,
you know,
as a,
as a species,
we have to get past that.
They have to figure out these super
duper smart dudes have to figure out
some new way.
no,
but right now it's so hard to do that
because their system is so oil based.
And it works so well,
you know,
I mean,
think about how much we travel.
Think about everything you do basically
is involved in going somewhere and
burning fuel.
You know,
I'm never,
I'm,
I'm home for a few days.
You know,
I'm home.
I'm here.
I mean,
I don't sometimes I never leave my house
at all for like a few days,
but there's still like,
I'm fucking using electricity.
I mean,
you know,
you're,
you're constantly using things that are
made of plastic.
You constantly consuming,
um,
things that people are produced from oil
and I don't see that changing.
How the fuck is that going to change?
You know,
we would have to come up with a new way
to reStructure the whole science.
So there would have to be some sort of a
reason to do that,
to get away from the oil.
They would have to be some drastic
reason.
It would have to be like a cataclysm.
It would literally have to be something
that resets society and causes us to
start from scratch because unless we run
out and we're not going to like,
we're not gonna like pay attention until
we run out.
It's going to be like,
oh shit,
we're out.
Fuck.
Now we do.
You know,
like literally they're not gonna.
They're not like protecting us and
giving us a nice safety net so society
can progress easily from here.
Until then.
It's not him.
Same thing.
Hot man.
Maybe it would.
Maybe it would help,
you know,
but that's not going to fix everything.
It's not going to fix everything.
It's,
it's,
it's definitely we've got to do
something.
This,
this oil thing does not work.
It's,
I mean there's a lot of weird arguments
about what oil actually is and some
people believe that oil is some sort of
a natural substance created by the
earth.
There's a whole book I got on it called
black gold stranglehold.
I haven't bothered to research online to
find out if it's been totally disproven
or whether it's bullshit,
but this guy's argument is that the oil
isn't fossil fuels.
It's not like really like plankton are
dead plants or shit like that,
like when people assume that it is
millions of years of that,
but with a finite amount left in the
earth,
but actually it's some sort of a natural
fluid that's produced by the earth and
if that's the truth,
if he's right and he's probably not
right,
but if he is right,
that's like the blood of the world.
Like we're like little vampire bugs
sucking off the blood of the world.
That's too trippy,
man.
Even if it,
if fossil fuels,
I mean even if it's not that,
you know,
even if it is the,
the decay of,
you know,
things that have existed on this earth
and we're consumed by death and decatur
and created this,
this substance that we use now.
Even if that's the case,
then it's like the shit of the earth.
Then it's like we're sucking the shit of
the earth out.
Well either way,
it's like we're sucking something out
that's a part of some sort of a natural
cycle.
You know?
It's all supposed to be in there.
It's like,
it's like literally like,
we're like fucking mosquitoes,
man.
We really are in the earth is us.
Yeah,
the earth is us and we're,
we're,
we're ticks sucking off the blood and
the most progress that we've ever had in
the history of our race was when we
started sucking off the blood of the
earth.
When we started cannibalizing mother
guy,
when we started eating our mother,
that's when everything started going
awesome.
So they created cars and computers and
cell phones and you knoW,
google voice in your pocket.
All that shit is all because that we
have this oil because we have figured
out a way to to make sure that the oil
and that we can transport shit with oil.
You could get planes to fly using oil
and we can.
I mean it's fucking bananas.
It's what a crazy society.
One thing comes along,
combustion engines figuring out how to
use oil for plastic,
for fuel,
for all these different things and
everythIng just goes buck nana's.
And then the question is,
what's next?
Have you heard about the smart dust
shit?
Yeah,
dude,
let me gliffy be our friend cliff.
He be over at epic games,
sent me this.
You're gonna,
you're gonna.
Have to google this.
You got to google up smart dust.
This is the most bizarre thing that I
think I have ever heard in my fucking
life.
These are,
listen to this,
these.
These are wireless devices that are the
size of grains of sand inside these
wireless devices.
The of grains of sand,
they have the ability to transmit
wirelessly.
They have a power source.
They have the ability to receive and
send data.
They have the ability to take images.
It's the size of a fucking green sand.
What websites?
Cnn.
This is on cnn,
how it is fucking bananas and they're.
They're literally talking about this
being this smart dust being a real world
web and the idea is that wireless
sensors,
they,
that you can use these wireless sensors
to monitor everything all over the world
all the time.
Like literally there will be no privacy.
So don't you think the smart desk
probably would already have existed?
you know,
if,
if this was true stuff,
it's probably already probably in our
room right now.
I mean,
do you think they're already been used?
Maybe it was telling us about it because
what did they do?
Use it first and then
is pretty easy to track.
I think it's pretty easy to track up to
a certain point like what people are
capable of.
But this.
I mean I don't,
I don't know if the guys who make the
most money of the top scientists who
they are incorporated by.
I'm not familiar with the scientific
world,
so I don't know if they.
They get record recruited by big
corporations or if they get recruited by
the government and who gets all the best
scientists.
You know,
who gets all the crazy genius do money,
money does right oil and.
well this thing is,
this is a really bananas fucking
project.
It's really hard to explain how crazy
this is.
There's a company called street line
that's installed 12,000
sensors on parking spots and highways in
san francisco and the sensors,
what they know is whether or not there's
a car in that spot and what they're
going to do is they're going to figure
out a way to give you data.
So say if you're going,
you know,
16th street and fair banks,
I need a parking spot.
Is there any available?
Yes,
there's one right here.
Go get it.
And they will tell you whether or not
there's traffic headed to that parking
spot.
Traffic's clear.
No cars nearby.
Like you can fucking go.
They'll tell you where the traffic is,
like the sensors on the street will be
able to pick up traffic and they'll know
what speed it's moving at.
There's,
there's gonna be no more speeding son.
They're going to be able to know who you
are and how fast you're going all the
time.
Like that's real.
That's going to suck.
That's okay.
So there's not going to be any sports
cars and sports cars.
You have to have to turn in your shit
and get some slow ass.
Only have horses,
you and the horses because horses,
you can't.
It's not ethical.
Yeah,
you can't.
Who cares about speeding on horses?
Well,
the sensor is going to be in the
streets,
so they'll be able to tell you that your
horse is going to factor.
It wasn't a speed limits when people had
horses,
right?
I don't think so.
It was actually better to go as fast as
you could.
You had the best.
You probably have the best world.
So we're going to go back.
If you fell as fast you could,
you know,
maybe we should take it easy and just
play it safe.
That's why you have leather shit on.
Let's just not gonna help you in your
land,
in your fucking hand on a cobblestone
street because the horse,
he saw a rat sensors to protect as a
horse freaks out sandman
man.
He's a fucking rat kuvan.
And you go flying and smash your head on
the curb.
That's it.
Horses,
horses.
Fuck oil.
Well,
this,
this real world web that they are trying
to create is one of the strangest
inventions that I think I've ever heard
about.
Um,
I,
I did not know that they were this far
along.
I mean,
these smart dust sensors can be
relatively small and portable,
portable.
What they're talking about with this is
that they're gonna.
They're gonna have trillions of these
things all over the world.
I mean,
this is the idea behind it.
Is this even possible though,
or is this just theories?
Hewlett packard's involved and they're
calling it.
They're calling it the central nervous
system for the earth and the coming
years.
The company plans to deploy a trillion
sensors all over the planet.
What?
How bananas is first of all,
how bananas is it that someone's letting
them do that?
If you're going to do what
I can't,
we vote on this before you put jesus
christ.
You know there will be no privacy.
There will be no privacy.
It will be impossible.
Someone will be able to detect this.
Can't happen because then if it's like
this,
then we can put sensors in the white
house.
yes it can.
Yes,
it can.
Dude,
I've been saying for a long time that I
believe that the next stage of human
beings is going to be the no secret
stage that's going to.
There's going to be some.
I mean,
it's going to be eventually it's gonna
get to the point where we can see each
other's thoughts and we can communicate
with each other and read each other's
minds and memories and ideas and we get
each other's ideas directly from each
other.
That's the next stage,
but it's not going to go directly to
that.
It's gonna.
Take a little pit stop along the way and
the pitstop it's going to take along the
way is no more privacy.
that's step number one.
Before the interface,
before human beings are allowed to
interface with each other,
where before we were allowed to become
one gigantic,
gigantic wireless mind and that's
possible
and park probably.
I think that's the future.
I think there's gonna be some sort of a
neural connection that allows everybody
to connect with everybody,
but before that happens,
they're going to have to come up with
something like this.
Before that happens.
There's going to be an intermediate step
and then the intermediate step will be
no more privacy.
You're gonna be able to watch people.
Fuck.
you're going to be able to do
everything all the time.
Maybe we're looking at the negative part
of this.
I don't think.
Now we can see.
Yeah,
that was going to say,
now we can see people.
Fuck,
I could fucking watch you watch you.
Not with my marrow blocker.
I'm going to make when I make my neuro
block or I got to leave latest
shit.
Yo.
That's what the problem.
Everybody's going to have a leadership.
It's going to be like computer viruses.
You're going to have to always be one
step up.
do you know there's something like
fucking 4,000
new kubota was at 4:40.
how many computer viruses are created a
day,
but at some been fucking crazy number.
Almost said bananas again,
which would have been annoying.
Caught myself to think about how crazy
that is.
They're going to get to a point where,
I mean,
how many is that?
40 two.
How many are out there?
Who gives a fuck?
Our.
Our point is ladies and gentlemen that
are privacy is slowly going away and I
think that that is a part of the natural
evolution of the human race.
I think that the human race iS evolving
to something that is no longer to deal
with embarrassment,
no way.
We're going to have a different set
needs because
our environment has changed so radically
from what our physical biology is coded
for that.
It's forcing this sort of an evolution
of technology is forcing us to evolve as
socially as well as it is evolving like
technologically.
Like as they come up with crazy and
crazier shit that dissolves boundaries
more and more,
we're forced to play catch up and that's
what's gonna happen.
If we get to a point where there's no
more privacy,
then we're going to realize how
ridiculous privacy isn't the first
place.
You know,
we're going to realize how ridiculous
embarrassment is.
Shame and all the stupid shit.
Like my daughter never wants to admit
when she shouldn't.
She's fucking too.
She never wants a minute.
You know,
she'll shake your head,
no machine making shit faces,
you know,
she doesn't want you to touch her.
Like they get embarrassed.
It's like it's,
it's almost a natural coding in our
system and I think eventually all that
stuff is going to deteriorate.
I think it's going to dissolve,
it's going to be crushed by innovation.
I think that's what's going to force us
to catch up because it's like the things
that we accept as part of like our
normal culture and the way behave.
A lot of it is just just what we get
used to.
I mean,
think about the shit that people get
used to another country.
It's thinking about the cultures and the
weird traditions that people have been a
part of like throughout history,
amish people and you know,
people who have plates in their lips and
you know,
and,
and nutty motherfuckers who do all kinds
of different rituals all over the world.
You know,
it's all what you get used to it.
we're just used to privacy.
Yeah,
we're used to it,
but it's not necessary.
This is going to be more important for
us to get rid of douche bags.
It's gonna be more important for us to
realize the importance of educating
human beings and raising human beings
that think correctly and to be
responsible for the human beings you
create and raise like you're responsible
for your fucking dog biting something,
but you're not responsible for your son,
you know,
like,
uh,
becoming a mass murderer,
you know?
Then it's just,
oh,
he got crazy.
I don't know what happened.
You know,
if your son kick someone's ass and does
a Bad thing to someone and breaks their
property,
you can get sued or you will have to pay
for that kid's medical expenses and you
have to.
But if your son is some fucking mass
murderer,
I mean,
what are they going to do?
Are they going to do?
Maybe you should go to fucking jail.
You made a monster.
You made someone that likes to kill
hookers.
How'd that happen?
Oh,
it just happened.
We don't even know the fuck.
You don't know.
You did something terrible.
You are so shitty.
And raising a human being that you raise
the human being that likes to kill and
eat other human beings.
Because sometimes that's totally just
nothing to do with parents.
I don't believe that.
You don't know.
No.
You think?
I think there are some thIngs that
happened to people genetically.
I certainly think so.
What do you.
They recognize that.
Yeah,
but that's not how you connecting gay
people.
Serial killers.
Because that's something that they're
not trained to do.
You mean that you mean they weren't
raised in in sexual desires?
This,
that's just just.
That's how you get people's eyes are
blue.
Some people's eyes are brown skinned
people like you know,
that's just It.
Wires get crossed,
likes to get sucked.
Dicks.
This person likes to stab somebody.
It's how your brain.
No,
that man sociopath's,
they're not exactLy sure where that
comes from and it's not necessarily that
every serial killers or sociopath.
Some people are just obsessed and insane
and broken and they have a lot of other
issues,
but they.
They think that there's a lot more
sociopaths.
People that don't care about other
people's feelings
a lot more than you think.
And they're not know though whether it
comes from nature or nurture.
I didn't really know a lot of
speculation like your dad molested you
stab somebody or your dad let you watch
when you're watching hormones.
Doesn't know if anything that's been
proven that watching horror movies,
playing video games is a release.
According to todd hollingshead from id
software.
He and I were having a conversation
aBout this the other night when he was
saying that that violence among kids has
gone down since popularity and video
games and violent video games has gone
up.
That it has sort of a cathartic release
sort of thing.
That's what they believe in Japan to do.
I think it's turning us into super
humans with dre.
I think there's better driving from
video games the other day.
Somebody just the world record for
sniper shooting.
A guy shot somebody a mile and a half
away.
You know,
I think the video thing is video.
I think video games,
hand to eye coordination is off the
fucking hook.
I mean,
when,
if you think about it,
like how much it is,
like for people that play video games
all day,
it's all about hand to eye coordination.
It's about shit like that.
And that's amazing.
Is that the use the same controller for
the xbox?
For those drones?
Yeah.
They use the xbox controls and
playstation controllers.
There you go.
See?
He used to doing that,
right?
I mean they,
they allow them to choose.
If you get to the army guys like can you
do playstation or more of an xbox?
Whatever guy do that are different.
WhaT we want to be remote boxes to me is
like,
you know,
it's like marvel versus dc.
There was never a dc kind of a guy like
marble,
right?
Know,
we'll fucking ps three.
I fuck a playstation.
Those are faggy sure.
There must be dudes like that out there.
Totally.
They go into the army,
but say,
man,
I was pissed off.
I had to play with a playstation.
I kill people with a playstation remote
mad.
I wanted to represent x blocks in my
country.
The navy is always nintendo.
We were all just kidding.
Just kidding,
you know,
but
they,
uh,
they do pilot those drones with,
with the same controllers,
which is really crazy.
When I,
when I firsT heard that,
that they do that,
I was like,
that is genius.
Makes sense.
I mean,
why not?
These kids,
they grow up and they're so goddamn
coordinated,
but that shit,
if you want someone to be awesome at
killing people with remote control
devices,
who the fuck would you get besides of
that?
Yeah,
they're,
they,
they're the masters.
Would they use it now in the army?
They use video games for going into
cities and stuff.
They have like,
you know,
call of duty's shit,
dude.
It's crazy
if you,
if you really watch like some young kids
that are bad ass video game players,
like I got a chance to watch this dude
named fatalities at the.
Jonathan wendell I think is his name.
I met him in vegas too.
It's a really cool guy.
He's a ufc fan.
I met him at one of the ufc and um,
he lives in vegas.
This dude is the number one.
He was at least at one point in time the
number one quake player in the world and
I got to see him play live one,
so it was at e three,
the big electronics a thing in the
conference or whatever the fuck it is
convention in los angeles and I got to
see him play quake live.
It was ridiculous.
Quake Is like fast twitch muscle fibers.
It's all like with quake is if you've
never played quake before and good for
you because that shit will addict the
fuck out of you that that shit.
EIght years of my life,
it's an awesome game and you're in this
three dimensional world.
It's a first person shooter,
so you're holding a rifle or a rocket
launch or something and you're running
through these really complicated three
dimensional mazes and you're fighting
other people in near real time and it is
real time.
If you hooked up to computers out and
you play against each other,
it's so fucking fun.
It's so fun.
It's so crazy.
It's fucking bananas.
Bananas again.
God,
it rockets are flying and rail guns and
you're electrocuting dudes with a light
gun.
Lightning gun,
lightening bolt gun so much goddamn fun.
I watched this dude play this guy alive
like he played like challengers,
like people will step up and play them.
It was the most,
the most ridiculous rape you've ever
seen in your life.
IT will be like brock lesnar fighting my
cat.
That's what it was like.
I mean these guys would just get
destroyed and you watch this guys like
hand eye coordination.
You're like,
man,
that's incredible.
To get that good at one specific type of
games,
get locked in,
you know?
That's totally applicable for like
warfare,
right?
Fuck.
We're learning how to kill people with
video games.
It's like that starfighter movie where
they went and they put a game out.
The scene would be awesome
games.
It's like all based off like a video
game or something like that was going to
get into the world.
Yeah.
Matthew broderick was.
See,
that's.
See that's a movie you can't watch
nowadays because that's gay.
If you wAtch that,
you were like,
this is the most unbelievable bullshit
ever.
I watched aliens the other day when I
was watching aliens.
They had the scene where he was talking
to the computer and the computer's like
old old ass text.
They haven't even figured out a graphic
user interface.
There was no idea that that would ever
take place.
So it was computers were all lights all
around you for no reason,
but was all lit up and big and stupid.
It's like,
oh,
that's your computer,
you know?
That's how ridiculous is that.
It's like star trek.
It's just.
Yeah.
So who knows what the fuck is ever going
to happen with the smart dust shit.
But you know,
I find it amazing that this is something
that's on,
you know,
cnn labs on,
on the internet.
But I'm not hearing about this anywhere.
Is anybody hearing about this?
Sure.
That was published April 1st.
By the way,
was it?
No mayfair,
you know,
just double checking out there.
It seems ridiculous.
That was yesterday.
It does seem ridiculous or something.
But it was yesterday.
So this is a real project,
a real thing.
If that's really happening right now.
I mean,
are they gonna?
Let us know when it goes live.
Don't see how like the government's
allowing that to.
They're just doing it.
There's
no,
there's no precedent.
Yeah,
but it's like google maps,
they're,
I mean,
they're there,
they're doing some nutty shit man.
They're just just.
I mean,
google maps actually has gotten in
trouble for a few things.
There has been some,
some disputes about what they are in
cities,
but what these guys are doing is,
you know,
I think they probably feel like they're
just creating a network,
you know?
I don't know.
I don't.
I mean maybe they're exaggerating the
capabilities.
Maybe there's some dispute about what's
going to be possible and what's not
going to be.
But the bottom line is they're not going
to stop here.
They're not going to stop with this.
You know,
if this is something that creating in
2010,
what the fuck are they going to have in
2020?
You know,
what,
what are they going to have in 2030?
There's gonna be some nutty shits on.
It's getting fucking crazy
or it's like us talking about 10 years
ago and nothing really like,
oh,
we don't have vcrs anymore.
We have blue ray,
you don't spend a lot of things have
changed in 10 years.
Yeah,
to a point,
but then you're also thinking like
on the high end level will the high end,
but the higher end of technology things
have changed drastically.
Like with the large hadron collider and
those guys in.
Whereas I think it's a Massachusetts
that are trying to recreate a son or
trying to figure out how to make a
fucking son.
What,
what is that about?
I don't even,
I don't even know the exact specifics of
that case.
You know,
I'll,
I'll look it up.
Scientists trying to create son.
So a ufc comIng up.
It's crazy that he injured his shoulder
hit.
That's not this ufc.
That was another one.
What's one is a familiar one?
I think his,
his,
uh,
his.
He was on the undercard of a rashad
evans,
I think.
I don't know.
be honest with you.
Yeah.
Nuclear fusion scientists attempt to
create artificial sun on earth.
Oh,
nothing's gonna happen wrong there.
That's definitely going to be fine.
They're goIng to make a fucking son.
We're going to have a little portable
sons that exist all around the earth and
that's,
you know.
Yeah.
Unless it blows up like the fucking oil
town.
What if you have your own portable
sunday?
Just followed me around and kept you
warm.
Yeah.
Unless it blows up like the fucking oil
tanker.
Could you Imagine?
Why do you always look at the bright
side of things?
Why do you guys look at the bad side of
things together?
Out?
We're like the odd couple like tom and
jerry.
There's two things on the shoulder,
like the devil and the angel.
Jerry.
ThIs animal house son.
Remember everything I guess.
Yeah.
It's been on a million things.
There was a comic that used to do an act
like that.
Norm macdonald was making fun of him.
Remember?
Remember he had like a logical,
logical left brain.
Right brain.
I'm so look,
we don't know what the fuck is really
happening with the smart dust,
but you got to.
I can imagine snort and people were
going to find a way to take a snort.
It may get high off of it.
This,
this got high up the smart dose dude,
the hp shit.
Yeah.
This is hilarious.
The research that this is,
despite these differences,
researchers say the dust theory,
that monitoring everything will benefit.
Humanity remains essentially unchanged.
They believe that this will benefit
humanity to monitor everything.
Maybe.
I think they might be right.
I think we might have to accept the fact
that technology is going to keep moving
forward and if technology keeps moving
forward,
what is the end result?
What's,
what's going to be at the end of the
rainbow?
What?
What is?
Is there a singularity as ray kurzweil
would say,
or you know,
terence mckenna says,
you know,
timewave zero know is there a moment of
ultimate novelty,
a moment,
a moment where they create something
that's so fucking crazy that it changes
everything.
This is probabLy the beginning,
man.
This smart dust shit is probably the
fucking beginning.
You know,
google was probably the beginning.
That was a part of it.
Oh man.
Google's browser.
That chrome browser is fucking amazing.
It's my favorite browser by far.
So this nuclear fusion thing,
this,
these scientists trying to create this,
this actual artificial sun or you know,
a natural side.
Yes.
It would actually be a son.
I mean it's of the same elements of the
stars may not have.
Right?
I mean if it's a son,
it's a son.
It's not like a fake tit.
Right?
Maybe it's the fucking son.
Well,
maybe they're just used throwing that
name son around.
It's just a really hot light bulb.
Well,
it just seems.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
What's a son?
It's a planet.
If you want to,
if you want to look it up.
It's in the telegraph.
Bright star as of yesterday.
Oh no.
Okay.
No,
it was published in since it was
published in 2008.
Two thousand eight.
All right.
Oh,
so I think they're moving.
No,
it's not a hope student there.
They're moving.
Oh my god.
Look at it.
Where it is right there.
Jesus christ.
This image of this thing.
It's like a fucking x men inside the
target chamber.
We're scientists will attempt to create
an artificial sun.
What the fuck,
man?
Yeah,
but what's the latest update?
I don't know,
research shows that these two guys are
just smoking.
A lot of weed didn't exist.
It was.
They just made it in a rush.
It's pretty fascinating when you
listen to it.
While it seemed impossible goal for
nearly a hundred years,
scientists now believe they are at the
break on the brake rather of cracking
one of the biggest problems in physics
by harnessing the power of nuclear
fusion.
the reaction that burns at the heart of
the sudden they really think they could
do this.
Wow.
Are people allowed to have like the,
the,
the ingredients to make a son.
But you know,
it seems like it.
You shouldn't be allowed to make,
have the ingredients to make science.
Well,
I mean,
what we can look at the manhattan
project basically harness the power of
his son.
You know,
that's a nuclear energy is right,
right.
Say you're not allowed to buy weed,
but you're allowed to make nuclear
explosions.
Fireball.
this is sort of an older story.
It seems like I'm fine and from 2008
with no a
no updates,
updates,
find whatever that scientIst is names,
and then just google that guy's name and
then under more options in google,
click the last month.
You crazy.
Fuck.
Yeah,
it seems like december 27,
2008 is when the,
uh,
now here's 2009 again.
Oh,
they're trying to make it in 2018.
That's when they believe that will be
fine.
But those,
the bottom line is some shit is fucking
happening.
That's the bottom line.
These,
while we think about tiger woods and you
know,
you hear the news,
new show they're putting together to
trying to put together a show where
tiger woods mistresses are the,
a get together with Jesse James,
mr says,
and they got to search for love.
They're going to have like a game
all together here to make it a porno.
Adam the one main porn star that
supposedly fucked with tiger woods,
just making a poor.
Now with tiger woods.
Lookalikes,
you could make,
you could make real shows with all those
girls and people would tune in every
week.
You could just put them as a cast,
that's what they should do,
like a scandal that comes out,
they should take the cast members and
put them as a cast on other shows like
you know,
like they'll start out with like a,
you put them on the apprentice,
you know,
like see if you can figure out a way to
make a business,
you know,
now you know,
you don't have any more money coming
from tiger.
You've got to figure out what you're
gonna do.
You're going to have to make money and
you're in the public eye.
So let's put you on tv.
So they get on the apprentice and they
try to figure out if they can start a
business.
Well that's no good.
Well,
uh oh,
I always wanted to be a singer.
Okay.
American idol.
And you put them all the whole american
idol.
The whole season tigers.
Mr says,
well,
you can't sing.
Can you dance?
And put them on dancing with the stars
all the whole season.
Tigers misses on dancing with the stars.
You know,
I mean,
I mean how many more fucking,
how many more of these stupid stories
can we have?
Wild shit is going on like people trying
to create songs and you know,
and these little tiny sensors that go
over the world,
how many people are aware of the smart
dust stuff,
the pr,
the amount that this should be a huge
fucking story.
There should be something that makes
everybody's jaw drop.
When you step back and go,
what are they gonna do?
They're gonna monitor everything.
What does that mean?
What does that go?
Does that mean?
I mean,
when is it going to start with just
little bits of information like there's
a,
there's a person in this area as they
can eventually get to a point where they
can have your image and you could see
everything everywhere and eventually are
they going to get to a point where
you're going to be able to tap into that
shit with your fucking.
It just seems like there should be
voting before this would ever happen for
real,
but there's not.
There's no voting on whether or not we
go to Afghanistan.
You vote a president in and then the
president gets to decide all sorts of
fucked up shit that nobody wants.
If you allow the american people to
decide,
90 percent of the shit we got involved
in would never happen,
so we have it set up where you don't get
to decide.
You get to decide on who gets to decide.
That's what you get to decide on,
which is fucking ridiculous because the
idea that one,
gosh should be trusted to fucking run
everything in this day and age where as
much as we know about how complicated
the world is,
that's fucking nonsense.
That's total nonsense,
but yet we accept it.
The right way to do it would be to have
everybody vote on things.
The problem with that is people are
fucking stupid.
They're really easy to manipulate.
You could.
You could tell them all sorts of shit
not true,
and the dumb ones would all buy it and
the dumb ones are more than half.
So now what do you do?
So it's almost like you have to have
someone who you think is pretty smart to
get into power so that he could make the
decisions for you guys and look out for
your best interest,
but that's when money gets involved and
they get fucking corporations and the
corporations come the long money to make
sure that you get an office.
But once you get an office like yo man,
like we really like the oil that we're
getting from the amazon jungle and we
like to keep getting that shit.
And you know,
there's some places we like to cut down
some trees.
There's a lot of bitches.
Hayden
got you.
I got you.
You want the trees?
It was good.
This is what we do.
We're going to go over there and we'll
give them a giant as loan.
They can't pay back.
And then when they can't pay it back a
little jack,
um,
take their shit.
And we've been doing that since fucking
the beginning of time.
There's,
there's money involved and when there's
money involved,
you can ever have a real power.
The real power can't be isolated in one
area and they can't be like all this
influence where like one group or one
person or one organization gets to
control shit because then everybody's
going to be trying to kiss ass to that
organization to get them to do what they
want so that they can,
they can conduct business and that's
what we're dealing with.
That's why people can't vote for
everything because a real democracy
would wouldn't work.
We're,
we're,
we're fucking babies were infantiles.
There's no way with the way we've been
living our society,
like were there some big daddy looking
out for us?
You know,
there's no way we can go from that to
like being able to be completely free
and vote for everything that happens.
It'd be too complicated right now.
That's just going to take a long time,
but I don't think it's ever going to
happen.
I think something's going to just bypass
it and launch our culture and launch our
civilization and to the next stage.
I think we're never going to evolve as
we are in this,
in this form.
I think this forum is all about fucking
and violence and chaos and laughter and
nonsense.
That's this life,
this life,
this life is all about love and
friendships and shit you like to do and
fun and it's hang on,
hang on to the big ship that is humanity
because some shit is going to change and
you're about to go through a new door
and when we go through that new door,
all this shit that you even worrying
about about whether or not you should
get a mac or a pc or whether or not
you're a democrat or republican or
whether or not you like family guy or
fucking fuck those hooks.
I like south park.
You know?
That's all going to be nonsense when the
big change happens and I think it's
common.
I think it is really fucking comment and
I think you see things like this little
smart dust thing and you see things like
people trying to create sons and you see
things like what's going on with with
the fucking oil spill,
where this going to be?
Some radical changes.
The way people approach extracting oil
from the ground.
Now people are going to demand this is
going to be a catastrophe,
you know,
I think some shit is change and I think
shit is so freaky,
freaky to think that this ridiculous
notion of 2012 being,
you know,
the end of humanity that is a date you
can actually track that.
It seems like it's happening that way.
It really would not be shocked if
december 20,
first 2012 actually does turn out to be
some sort of crazy invention or insane
innovation that catapults the human race
into the next stage.
You guys are going to be,
it's going to be nothing.
It's going to be completely nothing.
It's going to be like turning 2000.
It's going to be like the computer virus
that it might not be
dude,
or it might happen before then.
I mean,
it might be a rough estimate,
but I think there's going to be
something that takes place and I think
it's going to involve.
La has been added earthquake.
I think that's definitely gonna happen.
I think so,
yeah.
I think that's just lately I,
everyday on my,
uh,
chrome or my homepage,
the thing that pops up is my google
page.
One of the things my widgets is the
earthquake map for los angeles.
And if you've been watching ever since
that earthquake in san diego for the
last,
what was that?
A month and a half ago?
Squeak expert?
Or is this just rambling?
No,
this is.
I see the same eye.
I've Been falling earthquakes just as a
hobby I guess for the last seven years I
go to this website that just shows like
the earthquake map can do it.
If you believe in the secret,
you're creating earthquakes,
right?
No,
no,
I'm not.
But anyways,
like manifesting it current earthquakes
and ever freak you goddamn earthquake
projection center.
Yeah.
It just shows you that the earthquakes
recently,
but ever since the san diego,
san diego earthquake,
there has been so much activity in
Mexico,
like maybe,
maybe 100 times more than it normally
is.
Like just,
well this one's an earthquake right
under the house of some crazy mexican
drug dealer.
I know that's what I'm saying.
You need to put a layer drug dealer in
layer map over this google map to see
what's going on because ever since then,
like a month and a half ago,
it's been retarded.
You have a fear of earthquakes.
I don't have a fear,
but I'm interested in them and it's just
weird.
Like everyday,
like right in the last whatever,
couple of days a week there's been 920
earthquakes in los angeles or in
California and usually that hovers about
that same number.
LaTely though,
almost all of them have been in san
diego
so much.
Shit that can fuck us up man.
There's so much focus on.
I have an earthquake fetish.
That's right.
Oh,
I got another good story.
Let me make a out about how about this
guy who.
The courtesy of the pee pee pee bucket.
You can't even hold on.
Wait up here in the flashlight.
oh,
don't do that.
Don't go in the bathroom while you go in
the bathroom.
I'll take.
I'll take questions and when he comes
back from the bathroom,
we're going to talk about this dude.
His name is george wreckers and he is a
christian right leader and he just got
busted with a twink.
I love these stories,
man.
This dude is like this real staunch anti
gay activist.
He's a,
he's a board member of something called
the national association for,
uh,
research therapy of homosexuality.
And it turns out he's really gay.
it turns out that,
you know,
he was trying to pass all this
legislation.
He was a,
he's in the american college of
pediatrics or have pediatricians and
apparently the America american college
of pediatricians.
ThAt's like the name of it,
but it really like they hand out
literature according to this one
website,
choosing gays have something called
copper ofelia,
clp r o p h I l I a,
which means sexuality while playing with
shit,
copper ofelia.
So they were accusing gains of this
copper ofelia,
this failure,
this obsession,
the sickness and you know,
and saying how terrible gays are and how
adopted children that are adopted.
Gay families are all fucked up.
And meanwhile this dude,
the entire time was banging dudes.
It's really goddamn classic.
He was,
he was caught on vacation with something
called a rent boy.
He went to rent boy.com
rent boy.com.
and this is what he advertised for the
guy.
This is the guy that he went with.
He has a smooth,
sweet,
tight ass and a perfectly built eight
inch cock uncut and,
and explains that he is sensual wild and
up for anything.
So the cash.
this dude george records of north miami,
they catch him,
the leading scholar for the christian,
right?
They catch him at a terminal with this
gay escort and started taking pictures
and this is what the guys excuse was he
says,
I had surgery,
I can't lift luggage.
That's why I hired him.
Him.
That's fucking awesome.
And is pretty good.
That's awesome.
I think the tickle parties,
boy.com,
if you were a gay dude and you were so
tired of people fucking with other gay
dudes.
And so coming up with all these laws
that make it impossible for you to get
married and make it more difficult for
you to adopt children and make it more
difficult for you to,
you know,
get all sorts of shit.
You know,
that,
that shouldn't be denied from you
because of your sexual preference.
If you're not doing anything to harm
anybody else,
it's ridiculous.
They wouldn't even entertain that.
There's something wrong with it.
And this one motherfuckers just going
off just involved in so much,
so much legislation,
so much.
So much activism against homosexuals.
And meanwhile this fucking dude advisory
roles with congress,
the white house department of health and
human services and testifying in a
state's witness in the favor of
florida's gay adoption ban.
motherfuckers going to rent boy.com
getting twinks.
He's getting twinks.
If you know what twain started twinks or
the the little boys that gay dudes like
gay dudes like 19 year old boys are
like,
I'll have any muscle.
And they look like little boys twinks.
This dude was going and getting twink.
Twinks had surgery.
Surgery was twilight fans or something
like that?
No,
no.
Twinks,
the original twinks is a little,
a little gay dudes.
My mom's rude.
Dang,
because she was calling me a twink.
Wow.
Just called you a twink.
I'm sure your mom doesn't know what that
means.
Your mom's got some fucking betty boop
definition of
somebody that likes hard candy that she
heard on little rascals.
You know,
whaT the fuck does she know that this is
like the ted haggard
case?
Just as good.
It's like so many of these cases.
There's been so many of them.
It's almost impossible to math.
Um,
you know,
uh,
god,
what was that guy's name?
That was a.
he worked for marc faber,
who was another guy,
right?
there's been so many of them.
So many people that are,
that are,
that are anti gay turn out to be gay.
it's a favorite.
The one that was trying to bank kids.
He was trying to bang.
He was gay and he was trying to bang his
assistance and his,
uh,
one of those congressional pages.
That's what he was doing.
I think that's his name.
Favor,
whatever.
If it's not,
you know the fuck I'm talking about it.
It's,
there's so many of these guys that are
trying to fight against gay peopLe and
trying to stop people from doing things
and they turn out to be gay.
How do they not know that people are
going to check this thing?
How do you.
How do you not know that if you're a guy
who's like just spending an exorbitant
amount of time trying to fight the gay
agenda,
trying to stop gays,
were having the same rights as straight
couples trying to just suppress people.
Wouldn't you think they would look at
you?
What do you think?
They will check you out?
It seems like it's so weird when it's
always the loudest person.
That's nice.
It's an incredible.
The suppression of others for no reason.
When you look into someone trying to
suppress someone else's wants and
desires for no reason,
you have to look at that person and you
have to scrutinize where they're coming
from because that's not natural.
That's not a natural thing.
Like why would you care?
They're,
they're gay.
They're having fun.
You know what do you give a shit?
As long as he doesn't try to fuck you,
you,
you shouldn't have a problem with them.
You know,
there's a bunch of gay people,
they find the other gay people,
they have a good party together.
Who cares?
Why do you care?
You know?
That doesn't make sense if you care.
But if you do care and you're out there
fighting and man,
we got you.
We know now.
It's like,
it's obvious.
It's all of you.
You know what I mean?
How many of you,
how many of you,
the Larry Craig guy?
I mean,
how,
how many of you have to get busted?
It's,
it's,
it's fucking bananas.
Shit's bananas.
Bananas.
Bananas is sponsored by chiquita.
I should be.
Yeah,
but I'm going to be sponsored by the
fresh water because fucking my manager
and kiss my ass by the way.
I can't stop thinking about this
ridiculous dumb fuckers.
Don't fuck it.
I kissed it.
Tasted real to it.
I hope some big fat,
sweaty dude was inspected by number two.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
There's another senator.
They got busted watching porn and
congress.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
There's too many fucking people out
there telling other people how to live
their lives.
It's ridiculous and we shouldn't
tolerate it anymore.
You know?
At a certain point in time we have to
say,
fuck you.
That's enough.
You know,
it's too.
It's too crazy.
And every one of them that are telling
people what to do with their lives and
what they shouldn't be doing,
it doesn't hurt that every one of them
are fucked up across the board.
Whether they're musLims and want to
throw rocks at you for drawn pictures of
muhammad or dancing or the fucK it is.
Whether it's catholics,
whether no matter anybody that's trying
to suppress your behavior,
they're all fucKed up.
If you're not hurting anybody else,
you're fine.
Nobody's got this thing wired.
Nobody.
Nobody is control of the fucKing oil.
Nobody Knows what's happening.
The one was pouring out of the ground
40,000
fucking a day,
brian,
at least who knows?
There's no no answers folks,
and that's important because if we're
ever going to get past where we are now,
we have to realize that no one is.
We can't leave the control to like
someone who we think is more qualified
than us and someone who's on it,
like obama or the idea of obama or some
any guy being president and being on it.
You can't be on the world.
You can't be on the country.
It's impossible.
Nobody can.
And we have to accept that and until we
do,
we're going to fucking hurdle out of
control.
I agree.
And even if we do accept it,
I think it's too late.
I think what's going to save us and
what's going to change us is technology.
That's what I think.
Yeah,
totally.
I think when we realized,
I think we're slowly starting to realize
how full of shit people are.
We're slowly starting to,
as we get more and more intrusive into
people's lives,
we're,
you know,
we're exposing like another level of,
of understanding of human beings and
busting politicians and busting.
I mean,
there was stuff like that guy that got
busted.
Uh,
elliot spitzer.
Spitzer.
Yeah.
In New York.
I mean,
nobody got busted like that before.
Nobody's ever gotten better happening in
jail now.
Well,
you know,
that guy was a guy that was a very vocal
about the market,
about the market being all fucked up and
corrupt and you know,
and,
and talking about all these companies
and he believes that that's one of the
reasons why they went after him and
that's why they're one of the reasons
why they prosecuted,
persecuted him.
Meanwhile,
the guy was busting people for
prostitution and he was using
prostitutes,
you know,
he was like,
that was like another example.
He was a guy that was like all adamant
against we're going to stop
prostitution.
like,
oh,
what a good thing to stop.
Stop people getting their dick sucked.
Like,
well,
why would you do that?
Why don't you give a shit?
You got to really put so much effort
into that.
Well,
it turns out the reason why he's doing
this because you just covering up the
fact that he's using them.
Like why wouldn't he is no different
than all these crazy gay activists that
are secretly gay.
You know,
he's hating.
He is trying to cover it up.
So we should look at anyone that's like
a huge,
like loud person on a certain topic,
like the guy that likes slim jim's that
went to snap into slim seems probably
hates seeing it correctly at all the
time.
I was just joking the what we have to
look in as anyone.
The formula,
in my opinion,
and this is what I've seen to have out
of it.
You have to look at anyone that is
trying to suppress the behavior or the
desires of anyone else where it
shouldn't concern them.
Whether it's someone who is trying to
stop you from whatever the fuck it is,
whether it's masturbation,
whether it's anything.
If they're trying to suppress your
desire,
if they're trying to stop you from
marrying other gay people,
stop gay rights,
look at them,
find out what the fuck it is.
They're trying to suppress prostitute.
We gotta stop prostitution.
Find that guy.
He's getting his dick sucked is paying
for it.
He's a fucking freak.
He's a freak and he's crazy.
All the people that are trying to
suppress people from doing things that
don't affect the person who's trying to
stop them from suppressing things.
Just leave people the fuck alone and if
you don't lead people to fuck alone,
you're the problem.
You know,
and that's really what It is.
This eliot spitzer guy,
you know?
Yeah.
Maybe you were exposing,
you know,
these,
these flaws in the market.
Maybe you were exposing corruption,
but guess what?
douche bag.
You were also getting people locked in a
cage because somebody gave somebody
money to get their dick sucked,
which is fucking nonsense.
In 2010 you can,
you can go to jail because you can suck
someone's dick for free,
but if they give you $5,
you're a bad person.
That's ridiculous.
It is ridiculous.
That's completely ridiculous.
And then any,
anyone who's trying to suppress anybody
else's desires or needs and they're
trying to suppress them in a way that it
has nothing to do with them.
You got to look at them.
They're,
they're all,
they're all fucked up.
They're all doing something shitty.
Yeah,
I agree.
I'm glad you agree with me.
That was a.
That ramp tapered off at the end,
right?
It's pretty good.
At the beginning I had an important
point,
but somewhere around there,
through our market,
these things,
you just,
you lose the creative magic in
formulating your sentences.
You know,
I like your setup this week.
It's awesome,
but one thing I think I just killed
sperm,
that laptop on my lap,
just cooked my boss.
What are you going to do it like?
I do it.
You have the laptop off to the side.
That's the move is if you put your
laptop,
if you move this thing and you put your
laptop like you put your microphone
here.
Folks were fucking ghetto stuff.
Planned out situation there.
So we've covered everything that I want
to cover as far as ufc predictions.
People Keep asking me use predictions.
I never give you a few predictions
because who the fucK knows it's going to
happen?
I'm the super exciting fights.
The main event of course is spectacular.
Leo machida versus mauricio shogun who a
very,
very interesting fight.
You know,
a lot of people thought that maricio won
the first fight,
but if he did win it,
you know,
he didn't,
it didn't kill him.
He didn't,
he didn't really,
um,
you know,
he didn't stop him.
He never really heard him badly.
He never really had a real dominant
moment in the fight.
He just edged them.
A lot of people felt like he edged them
and a very exciting fight.
And I tHink that,
you know,
leonardo is going to have a completely
different strategy most likely for this
flight.
Very excited to see that he's a very
strategic dude.
And uh,
I think also he's going to be the both
guys got to be more prepared.
They're going to know what the other is
capable of.
They're going to review the first fight
and go over mistakes,
go over when they landed and you know,
and go over like maybe tendencies that
each might have that might,
maybe they can exploit.
So I think it does.
The second fight is going to start out a
chess match.
Now they're going to be a both guys
going to be doing things that they think
are going to benefit them in this fight
that maybe they didn't do in the first
flight.
Maybe we'll find guys might start off
the fight a little bit more cautious.
That could be interesting.
You know,
cfo maybe show them,
plays the role of a counter striker
initially or maybe they Just get to it
like it's around six.
Maybe they just fucking go out each
other.
That's very possible to,
you know,
um,
maybe that even more so because of the
controversy involving some of the fights
lately where guys haven't been exciting
like the anderson silva fight where he
kind of slacked off over the last two
rounds and people even criticizing jose
aldo for his last round of his fight.
So If that's the case,
if they're affected by that stuff,
maybe they might come out and try to
prove a point.
I don't think that's going to happen
because to too much is at stake and both
guys are too dangerous.
They're both two of the most dangerous
and explosive guys in that light
heavyweight division.
And anything can happen.
So that's my prediction for the main
event.
Karate guy,
his cheetah.
Cheetah.
do you think,
what do you think his karate as well?
Martial art in general.
Well,
what machIda does is very smart is he
combined the good things of karate with
more thai and jujitsu and wrestling and
boxing,
you know,
but there's a lot of good stuff in
karate.
The,
the ability to leap in and leave out
like the way they fight.
They're very.
The footwork is different than like
moitai guys,
more thai guys,
more like they learned that their light
on their feet but they weighed in and
they get real close to each other and
attack,
you know,
and they check kicks and attacks the
karate guys,
they're all,
it's almost like fencing,
like explode,
explode out.
And if you're not used to fighting
machida he's super hard to deal with
because that,
that explosion that is fucking throws
you off many.
He leans way back and he dives in and
he's super accurate with things and iF
he catches you with one of those,
he could fuck you up.
it lightens you up like pot shot at you
from a distance.
You're in trouble.
That's what happened to rashad evans.
He started just lighten them up.
He started like laying back and he comes
in and blast them and then once he does
it a couple of times,
that's all he needs to do.
You don't even need to hit you a couple
of times before.
You're like a little bewildered and he's
so good at that.
He did that too.
So could you.
You know,
he did that to tiago silva.
Stopped him at the end of the first
round is a fucking killer,
man.
He's a killer and he's going to be
trying to do that even more on shogun
den in their first fight.
He's going to be more fired up,
more motivated.
I think he's going to be even better.
And then show gun.
He's got to be super confident because
he feels like you won that first fight.
He feels like he got robbed them
decision.
So he's going to be confident and he's
gonna be fucking coming in guns blazing
and leo's going to be confident and the
other is going to be more motivated,
better strategies going to be an awesome
fucking fight.
Okay.
Are you just,
you just go buy a karate studio and
you're just like,
okay.
That little 15 year old has a black
belt,
you know,
that's your sport that you can get a 15
year old can be,
have a black belt.
Are you kIdding?
Well that's
the problem with the thing they call the
mcdo.
Joe's joe's the muck jo jo syndrome is
that,
you know,
when martial arts became popular in
America,
I guess in the sixties or whatever,
when people started watching Bruce Lee
movies in the seventies and shit,
what happened was people got really into
karate and karate became a business and
they open up karate schools all over the
world,
you know,
and people wanted to learn how to kick
people's asses and then it became like
some bullshit mysticism thing and a lot
of bowing.
And they're very cult like,
man,
if you never been to karate.
Schools are a lot of martial arts
schools.
My taekwondo school is very cult like,
you know,
they're like,
the,
the sensei can do no wrong.
And everything is.
Yes sir.
It's like they're never a,
an even and equal with you,
which is one of the beautiful things
about jujitsu.
Jujitsu is totally the opposite.
Your instructors just liKe you.
He's super cool and just like you,
you don't have to call them.
I mean,
if you do call him sir.
It's out of respect.
But he's gonna I approached her brother,
my friend to call me sir.
You Know john.
John would shadow would laugh if you
call them.
Sorry.
He's just a friendly,
cool guy that knows something that you
don't know.
He's going to show it to you.
So like jujitsu,
the,
it's way more rare for a 15 year old gay
black bell and it really,
really hard to get your black belt in
jujitsu.
Martial arts,
they have much lower standards than
jujitsu.
Most of them do.
And karate.
A lot of schools can.
If you go to a real karate school,
like a real,
you know,
okinawa and karate school or a cushion
karate school where they're like really
like rigid traditional,
old school.
WaIt,
no,
they're not going to give you a fucking
black belt if you're not ready.
You got to get that back,
but you gotta earn that shit.
You gotta want to masa yamas fucking
schools.
One of his affiliates,
you know those guys that's.
Those are serious hard motherfuckers.
Those,
those karate tournament,
they fight in especially the kill
cushion karate tournaments.
Those dudes are fucking animals.
They don't punch to the face,
but they kick to the face and kicked the
body and kick to the legs.
They're fucking tough,
man.
That's a.
That's a hard,
hard sport.
So our hard martial art,
if you go to those schools,
you're not going to be able to get a
nine year old and get them their black
belt.
But if you go to one of these,
like fred valori schools,
they used to be like the united studios
of self defense when I lived in
Massachusetts for fucking 12 years old
and you got a black belt that's
ridiculous and you can't crack an egg.
Like they don't have any idea how to
fight.
They don't.
They're completely lost their,
they want to do like high kicks and
catia and fucking knife and strike you.
Like they literally don't know how to
fight.
They like taught how to do this stupid
dance,
you know,
they don't even have contact when they
spar.
I can,
most of the schools.
Could you hear that?
The boy scouts now have a badge for
playing video games.
I thought it was crazy because then that
doesn't that defeat everything that boy
scouts about like adventures outdoors
and yeah,
they have a video game badge and like
government man,
they want you to become a.
Or they want you to target their drones.
Could you hear obama made a joke about
fucking drones?
How do you know the,
you know,
the whole thing with obama and he told
jokes and jay leno told jokes.
Jay leno kind of bombed.
No,
I didn't hear about this.
The white house.
I think there's a white house.
White house press correspondents'
dinner.
I thinK that's what it's called.
Right?
You didn't hear about this.
Why I ignore all
you got to checK this out because it's
fascinating.
Obama goes on and,
and,
and everyone's like,
obama did so well.
Opie and anthony were the only ones that
said obama didn't do well and I fucking
completely agree with them.
He just butchered the jokes,
like the timing sucked,
but the jokes were pretty well written.
I think some of the guys from the daily
show or something running for him and
um,
the jokes put his delivery is terrible.
It's all clunky and,
but he,
he got big laughs.
But one of the jokes he did and no one's
even talking about this,
one of the jokes he did,
he said,
the jonas brothers are here.
Where are you?
Jonas brothers?
There you are.
And he said something about his
daughters,
you know,
that his daughters,
uh,
you know,
his daughters are very beautiful,
but I want to let you know,
don't even think about it.
I've got two words for you.
It was like spy drone or soMething.
Drone.
What of those drones called by drones.
But like you said,
I have two words for you.
I like unmanned drone.
Like what,
what,
what are you saying?
Mr.
President,
you're joking around that if one of
these boys,
who by the way are like the most wishy
washy,
chris
non-offensive non-dangerous,
they have fucking these white.
You're upset at how these bracelets on.
Yeah.
Dude drawn away and fucking called it.
I think that's pretty funny.
It's not funny.
He's talking about things that kill
innocent people every day.
I use that thing in Pakistan and those
things,
they launched them in the,
in,
into these villages and launched some of
these mountain sides and people get
jacked left.
Yeah.
But you can also say that sorts of
people that get killed.
You could say that about jokIng about
anything.
airplanes,
You know,
I mean there's a.
You can joke about black helicopters,
but black helicopters kill people for
the government.
Patchy helicopters,
you know,
I mean drones.
That's pretty funny.
He says taking something that's like
kind of in the news,
your example is ridiculous.
And,
and here's,
here's the thing,
when you're the president of the god
damn United States,
it's just like when George Bush waS
president and he said,
where are the weapons of mass
destruction?
None under here.
Right?
It's like looking under his desk.
Yeah.
But drones aren't just made for
killings,
for spying and stuff,
you know,
they have hellfire missiles on them.
They're there to find people that are
bad and lost,
but there's also implying he's going to
spy on the jonas brothers.
He's going to kill them.
Right with,
with something that they've been killing
people with light lighthearted.
It's not like that's.
I think that's attacking somebody that
you want to attack the person.
I think that's ridiculous.
If you're getting angry about that.
You think that me saying that,
him saying that is attacking him.
No,
no.
You're obviously taking it like in
America,
right?
I can't believe he's joking about this
shit.
Go man,
brian,
when you're the president of a country
that is literally fucking the whole
world.
I don't see that
evolve into wars overseas and these
weird things that happened in Pakistan
that are,
I don't know who approves them or how
exactly they work where they have these
drones that fire these missiles at these
people that we don't like and all sorts
of other people die,
but that's not something I would joke
about if I was the president,
but there's plenty of shit to make you
think that he's joking.
Also kInd of acting
like my mom getting mad about him.
I can't believe he said a joke.
It's a dumb joke.
I don't know why he would think it's
funny.
I don't know why he would think killing
boys that want to fuck his guy thing.
It's fucking hilarious.
It say that to the jonas brothers.
I would say that hilarious.
It wasn't a good job.
It was like you've got the worst
response of any of his bits.
It wasn't well delivered either.
I think it's brilliant.
I can't believe you think that because I
think I wouldn't say that if I was the
president that's retarded,
which is saying something really.
You don't think there's any comment and
that there's something very serious
about being a person who's responsible,
at least indirectly for many,
many people dying because of these
fucking drones.
Many people crying.
Many families devastated.
Many people lost theIr children.
Many people lost their loved ones gone
forever,
but because it's taking place in
Pakistan doesn't freak you out.
what did we use involved In drone
attacks in Ohio would have kids you went
to high school with got fucking killed.
They got their legs blown off because
obama is using drones to target al qaeda
in Ohio.
Wouldn't that wouldn't?
You're saying,
well,
what if though joe,
you're saying,
what if not,
what really happened?
He just brought it.
I see what you're saying.
No different than Ohio for you to think
that it's okay and Pakistan and not okay
in Ohio because I didn't say it because
it's.
That makes it a what if joe,
you're making.
You're making it seem like that.
I.
I'm that sensitive about the middle east
and stuff where I'm not.
I don't think about that shit.
You know,
you're getting really sensitive about
our war and our troops and everything.
Oh,
I'm not thinking like,
oh,
I just made a joke about murder.
Yeah,
I figure you're getting really sensitive
about obama just doing a bad job.
You know?
That's just a bad joke.
It's a ridiculous,
irresponsible joke.
I think to make a joke like that in the
middle of two wars that people don't
approve and all these things that are
happening in Pakistan with unmanned
drones,
I don't think you should be making jokes
like that.
It less.
They're fucking hilarious and that show
was lame as fuck.
I think it's.
I think it's pretty funny for it when,
especially when the president says,
I think it's hilarious.
I think it makes our president seem
edgy.
I think it seems like he's not playing
dumb and trying to butter like nerf are
fucking ears.
He's actually saying something that's
like,
wow,
that's kind of blue.
That's kinda crazy.
Dude.
Military the president does now the key
to the drums.
Oh,
so his joke is not only,
it's not correct as well,
you don't think they would let hIm
borrow the key so he could kill the
jonas brothers?
Is that what you're trying to say?
Thank you very much for trying to
answer.
Yeah,
but you're saying like you're,
you know your,
like your joke on baby blowjobs,
you're saying like,
you know,
that's bad to say,
how many people are child molesters and
stuff.
If I wasn't,
no.
Here's an example that you need to use.
If I was a child molester and I was out
there below and babies and then I did a
joke about baby blow jobs than it will
be the same as what the president is
doing.
So the president is killing people with
drones right now while the president is
the spokesperson for the country and the
country is in fact at war and has
military that is killing people with
drones.
I just,
I see it as at the top of the food
chain.
I see why.
I see why you're upset,
but I just,
I just don't see it.
I just didn't see it.
I understand that you don't see it,
but I think it's hilarious.
Understand.
Here's the open.
Anthony were mad too about this.
Um,
no,
I think they were talking about
something else.
we're talking about his jokes bombing.
they would just send me that they were,
you know,
they were open.
Anthony were set at his delivery.
His delivery was Tyler Norton.
Norton was going crazy.
It was run on norton,
but he's also loves jay leno,
you know,
and he was honest in his assessment of
jay leno.
Jay was like rushing through it.
He was lIke rushing through his joke,
but the jokes were lame.
He knew he had bad jokes and I think he
thought it was going to be an easy crowd
and he could just squeak by,
you know.
But,
but I think he realized when he got
there that there was some pressure on
him.
I think a lot of people don't like him
now they're poor.
Fuck,
you know,
everybody's all mad at jake [inaudible].
He took his job back.
Like why does everybody give a shit?
you know,
conan o'brian gets 35 fucking million
dollars and it gets to go to tbs,
whatever.
That's funny how he straight up lied
though on the,
on the um,
what are 60 minutes the other day about
twice,
twice.
And he said that the reason why he got
fired,
not lenovo,
because his payout or leno's payout was
more or something like that.
But they are like,
nbc is like,
that's a lie.
Their payouts were exactly the same.
They also said something like,
uh,
maybe he didn't know.
Maybe it was just mistaken.
Well,
he didn't.
There was another thing somebody told
that by agents or something to something
about nbc losing money.
But what I find odd though is that I
checked ratings the other day.
Jay leno's ratings and conan's ratings
are almost exactly the same as they
were.
If you were going from year to year from
last year to this year or whatever.
Exactly the same.
So there's no money.
There's no like leno's number one makinG
$50,
million dollars extra month.
It's been.
He was saying he was,
but maybe before.
Yeah,
for what they're thinking,
that he's eventually going to bring it
back to where he was beFore that he's
gonna take over the reins and,
you know,
have it back to where it waS because
when he left he was number one.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
The whole thing is this,
a stupid argument is like,
who cares?
it's just entertainment and not only
that,
it's not the best entertainment.
If kony had a talk,
not a talk show rather,
but like a,
um,
a sketch show,
I think that would rule.
That's what I would like to say because
I think conan's the best parts on conan.
It was when he does those sketches,
like when he did those,
uh,
the baseball player,
the 18 hundreds baseball players when he
went there and played baseball with them
and he was talking 1800 speak fucking
hilarious.
That was way better to me than his
interviews.
And these interviews are cool,
but most of the people that he's talking
to,
it's like,
what are they doing?
They're just selling some shit.
I jusT want you to see their movie.
They just want you to buy their book or
wants you to listen to their music.
It's like,
you know,
it's like he's just helping themselves.
Shit.
That's really all it is.
So bad in general of how bad,
like a jimmy fallon,
they have a whole.
They had a whole like 10 minutes sketch
the other day on subway and it was a
commercial and it was like people were,
there was actors involved and they were
like doing skits all about subway.
Oh,
subway subs.
Subs like $5.
Footlongs was the whole thing they're
talking to and it was an ad for like 10
minutes.
So.
Oh well,
you know,
if it was funny,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have a problem with it.
You know,
especially for the flashlight,
one commercial where they rip off Brian
Collins act.
There's a commercial,
like an old spice commercial where this
guy's like doing.
Look at my stance
on the horse and the horse.
I have an apple tv.
That is brian calories serious.
Fuck.
That's like one of the most popular
commercials I do like super rich.
Now That guy sounds like brian couns act
and all these people are saying that,
and apparently advertising executives do
that all the time.
They see comics,
they go to comedy clubs and get an idea
from their ag.
Here's something,
here's something weird.
There was a movie called miss march.
It was a,
I forget the pli.
I was half drunk watching this movie and
uh,
the chat or it's the craig robinson,
is that his name?
He played a character in this movie
called horse cock dot mpeg.
And the whole time I'm watching it,
it's like they call listens character.
Yeah.
And that whole thing,
they'll joke was his,
that his character.
He's a rapper named horse cock dot j
mpeg.
And the whole time I'm thinking like,
that's kind of weird because of your
horse bit material about being a mr
han's dot mpeg.
No,
that's weird.
But it's weird that like,
how there's so much similar things like
that.
And I'm wondering like,
you know,
writers and people in marketing and
commercial and stuff,
if they really just,
you know,
that's a real connection and anybody
could come over really hotdog mpeg.
Look,
it was a real video Man.
yeah,
but only you of all people focused in on
a point that was called mr [inaudible]
dot [inaudible].
No,
I don't.
I think that's silly.
I'd absolutely.
That's what it's called.
You can't.
I mean,
just because I've talked about it on
stage.
I mean that's what.
That is what it is.
You can't say that somebody stole
that.
I didn't say it.
I just think it's weird that there's so
many similar things.
Like you're saying,
right?
Brain talents that's stealing.
I know they stole it.
You know,
the,
all these comics have recognized that,
that it's like the guy's like doing a
version of brian callen,
you know,
and probably,
he doesn't even know probably.
he's probably just some actor and he's
funny and he just has the same voice.
No,
it's not the voice.
It's the,
the,
the way brian talks about things.
He exaggerates like sometimes I just
take a horse stance.
I just stand there.
He's got a ridiculous act like look up,
look up my body toned and defined.
I'm eating a peach,
sometimes,
like to eat a peach.
This guy's like doing callan callan has
this ridiculous character.
It's like someone doing that.
You might be a redneck character like
going up and doing jeff foxworthy,
even if he's not calling himself.
Jeff fox were like,
you know where he got that came from.
But jeff foxworthy famous was Brian
Collins,
not famous.
like if brian cowen was super famous and
then this commercial was out,
everybody would be like,
this guy's ripping off brian cowen,
you know,
I was like,
he's doing brian cowen.
I think that shit's real common.
I think they do it all the time.
Cell dies.
Hmm.
I don't know about that.
Sam.
Tripoli seems to think so.
Sam shirt play things.
A lot of things that aren't true.
Really?
Like what?
Oh,
it's
two hours and two minutes.
That's just about it.
So next week we're going to fuck.
We're going to this week we're going to
fuck one a's,
right?
We're going to talk.
Nah,
you know what my manager,
I'm sure,
but not want me to fuck one of those
things.
Especially this one whole wine bottle.
Well,
you're already seeing it.
The shit out of that one.
UM,
so,
um,
I think the,
I mean definitely send me some twitter
messages if you think that it's
ridiculous to,
uh,
you know,
to think that I should not accept a
because somehow
this is going to hurt my career.
I think it's ridiculous.
But I would like to hear your thoughts.
Am I allowed to accept it?
Yeah,
you can.
We can split the screen down in the
middle.
This is brian's part of this show is
sponsored by fleshlight.
My side is not hearsay shuchita banana
long and I want to let cbs,
nbc,
and abc know that I'm ready and willing
to do your family game show chiquita
banana on this side flesh.
So,
uh,
I'm doing,
what do we need back here?
Do we need a monitor or do we need a
green screen?
That's the other question is should it
be a monitor or green?
Sixty inch led 3d dlp,
dlm.
No.
Lcd samsung.
that when you have people at home would
have to watch with goggles on and we
will be blurry and everything else you'd
be in three days.
Awesome.
no,
that's ridiculous.
Probably wouldn't even work.
I probably wouldn't transmit through
this little shitty ustream.
What if it did
fuck's wrong?
So,
uh,
there's a question too.
Should we do a green screen?
I say yes.
I'm looking at it right now.
I'm like,
it would be dope if we have an image of
Space behind us.
That's the move,
right?
You have to do that.
Apparently we can't do that with this
stream producer though when I'm worried
about,
is that the,
the uh,
ustream producers,
the only way we can get this thing up on
itunes or we're just using the eastern
producer to take the signal out to the
internet.
So we'll plug this into your computer
and it'll be an input on eastern
producer.
So we'll still be able to use.
You should produce or.
Yeah,
you should.
You know how this thing works for sure.
I can try castor figured out in five
minutes.
That's how easy it was.
God damn genius.
Without him we would be doing the same
thing,
but it would suck more and probably the
sound would be going on in the
background.
All right.
Green screen.
Most people think so.
I think that's what we're going to go
with.
Let's unanimous.
Thank you.
Everybody.
Like,
yeah,
it's all green screen and everybody's
saying greenspan,
they don't want to monitor monitor as a
gay greenscreen is cool,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
So that's what we're gonna do.
That is the next stage.
So we have this and check this shit out.
Look how this thing does at the end of
the show.
I go like that and it goes down fucking
crazy,
man.
I got that shIt at z gallerie yo.
So,
uh,
that's our show.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we will see you next week.
Tuesday as always.
You know,
how we rock it basically the same every
week.
And um,
hiS thing is slowly but surely getting
more and more,
more and more complicated,
but more professional,
smoother.
The sound for the itunes version is
going to be way,
way,
way better now,
um,
with these professional microphones and
the high end mp three player and all
that jazz.
Um,
the video should be better now as well.
And,
uh,
eventually,
like I said,
we're going to have that and next week
we're also going to have hd camera.
So we'll have two cameras to choose from
so we can switch back and forth,
just get crazy.
And uh,
eventually we're gonna have this thing
set up like a real studio.
There's another,
there's another couch chaIr over here
and we'll have it lit up better to just
right now it's kind of funky.
Um,
so,
uh,
it rolls on.
Thank you very much for 200 and I'm glad
you guys enjoyed it.
Fleshlight fleshlight.com
is where you can go if you want to fuck
a rubber pussy and uh,
that's it.
So we'll see you next week.
Take care.